this week on the trove Jodi podcast we
finally have our first woman on the show
and she's one of the strongest people
I've ever met an actress and
entrepreneur who made a video diary
during supporting her husband in his
battle against cancer while raising two
kids and her name is Holly Matthews it's
just so many similarities in who we were
it was weird
if anyone had ever said this amount of
you know cringe like love at first sight
stuff but we met and we were like fully
equals
he wasn't in pain like we're talking
like we were in the Caribbean and May
this year and within a month he was dead
it was weird three days I were in
surgery
he was wallpaper in Texas his bedroom
you know like he didn't give a [__]
advantage like I mean he wasn't supposed
to be but it was the hardest block like
mentally the strongest blog and not like
a stiff upper lip or anything like that
just like pure I'll do it the [__] I
want like on every level we were sat me
and the girls and we were right in 32
reasons why we love rocks I love that
and as I'm writing this I mean the the
poignancy of this it's like not lost on
me like we were right in that and I
looked over and he was sort of
chattering and I thought he on the forum
to someone oh my god he's not he's
having a seizure
you know he thought he was fine and the
doctors had to say Ross I'm really sorry
but you're not going to be saying
anything that's right and in the middle
of books buying nappies and like thing
would be put on the beds or whatever and
I sat in the car
afterwards it was raining sat in the car
it's dark I'm sitting there with nappies
and looking at like next where we've
been you know the month previously
buying house stuff and I'm like what the
[__] comfortable with being a woman born
a woman born a woman got all the bond a
girl everything under the hood yeah so
we're gonna get serious that's slightly
serious that's a question side this is
soul a while ago I was mourning on
Twitter and YouTube saying all these
vloggers so we've got in on YouTube who
hi guys and my life's perfect I'm just
off to do this Sutton the other and I'm
gonna sandwich today I was just saying
it's not really an accurate depiction of
real life and it was brought to my
attention that you are the person who's
doing that best right now so watch
summary videos and very quickly I
realized that they were right
then I knew Sharri I wanted to get you
on the podcast we'll be waiting for the
right time and yeah I sort of let you
get on with everything you've been going
on with but do you want to sort of tell
us how use of did things differently on
your vlogs to the regular people out
there the more recent stuff has come
about and me talking about my journey
with my husband having cancer and grade
four brain cancer and with the girls my
two daughters and just documenting it
and we spoke a little bit earlier but I
sort of for me it was kind of
it was soft through fall it was like one
day the girls my daughter's I want to
understand what's happened and this will
make sense of it for them too for myself
like to kind of at some point go back on
it and go [__] that really happened and
what was it because I can't remember
many of the videos now like I'm not
gonna go back and watch them all and
like torture myself I can't really
remember them at some point I think I'll
want to look at them and kind of go okay
what happened like really make sense of
it and then the other way reason was
that I don't want to say the same thing
over and over again and when you've gone
through something painful and everyone
wants an update you have to repeat the
same sad story over and over again and I
just thought I'm not doing it I'm not
doing it and in so I put it all out
initially when the recent most recent
stuff when Ross was dying I thought
about I'm gonna just do a video or blast
it out to everyone I won't have to say
anything and honestly the truth is since
Durbin that I haven't had to tell people
the story like not won since Ross has
died I've never had to say Rostow like
ever like a goal I mean yes it's been in
the press and stuff as well as being on
YouTube but I've never had to go in
anywhere and it's it's a weird thing but
I'm sure it's kind of positive so that's
kind of how I and and I just I I never I
don't edit very much mostly because I
can't really edit so I just it's because
it's raw as [__] it's so so real I'm not
sure like let's see what is in my head
and then even when like the mess up bit
so I'm like mumbling stuff I just think
oh so what like you're right like I'm so
bored of like perfect like it's not
realistic and it doesn't interest me at
all I don't want to watch like hey I'm
so perfect and my life is amazing just
getting a coffee at night it's just it's
door like I want it when I speak to
people and that's why I like your show
is because I want to know what like what
people are passionate about and what
excites them and what I don't know like
what scares them I'm not interested in
like small talk when I watched your
video of the first time if
and hit as like a ton of bricks to be
quite honest with you because he has
this this woman who not girl woman who
obviously is a way that she's about to
lose the love of our life who's going to
spend the rest of our life with this guy
and all of a sudden you know life takes
a turn and that's it and you have it to
try and make sense of that and when you
were speaking through the pain and I
think maybe it's the first video I might
see was before you went at the hospice
you support with such clarity and yeah
you had your [__] together in a way that
I've not seen anyone speak well going
for something so painful and I was like
[__] hell hey how much pain she's
going through and be held together you
were was it was mind-blowing and and the
Geordie accent didn't hey life is always
connected with you and it just blew us
away I think just like for me like just
being just being honest was helpful like
it just find it easy I don't really know
how else to be with that stuff and I
think there's always in the back of my
mind this might help somebody else there
is always that element there that if I
talk about it and I talk about in a way
that you know like the weird stuff that
you go through especially in grief and
pit and like caring for somebody this
there's weird stuff that no one talks
about that you kind of you don't really
understand until you go through it you
are saying things that I mean I've been
through death before and you are saying
things that resonated with me where you
were like it feels like me whole entire
worlds just like changed like and not in
a cliche way but you're like it's almost
like I've gone outside and everyone's
talking a different language and I'm
like I didn't get the memo like when did
this happen
now since Ross has died it's like I've
had to draw a line under whatever
thought before whatever I thought the
rules the boundaries the limitations
what judgment I had on certain
situations like it's gone all of its
gone because Ross is dead and saw
nothing makes sense nothing that I
thought makes sense makes sense or it's
like I have to at the minute I feel like
I'm going through this transition period
where I'm like okay just I'm allowing
myself to you
like I think people think I'm late never
crying so I cry I just thought cry for
hours that just because I'm working on
myself all the time like I just don't
feel that I need to but I think now it's
like this time where I'm like what does
it mean what does it mean for us now
where I'm at now and I'm constantly like
just reworking what that is now and I
think I'm sure that you know I mean
certainly that you said is why like you
kind of got that and I'm sure that's the
case for a lot of people but people
don't talk about any of this stuff
because we either you know like stiff
upper lip just forget about it don't
talk about it or we just we feel like we
need to wrap it up and like it'd be fine
after a bit and I think someone said to
me that grief particularly it doesn't go
away and this totally makes sense to me
and it's where I'm at but if you fill
the rest of your life with good stuff
it's almost like it seemed smaller in
comparison to the good stuff around it
and that makes perfect sense to me like
that's what I'm doing now can we so
retrace the steps then and can you give
us an idea of what your life was like
with Ross before the diagnosis and then
what it was like when you got the
diagnosis so me and Ross we met and I
was with someone else
we met on a job for Pimm's we're both
doing I was an actress nice to do like
promotional work and Ross was pretty
much only on that job because it was a
massive shocker he realized that fit
girls do promotional work and he went
along to this interview and he was like
get me into this like you got long let's
go alcohol and women it's basically or
two things we went he went both both of
us were paid to be at home we were paid
reserves both of both of us and won't
cancel the job and we had to get called
in so we will live it because I was
getting paid to be at home originally
and then sitting out to go in so we both
like didn't want to be on the job both
found job met each other and there was
just so many similarities in who we were
it was weird like if anyone had ever
said this amount of in like fringe like
love at first sight stuff but we met and
we were like fully equal straightaway
and there was lots of like I grew up on
television so in a time when we didn't
have social media so I was on a platform
before everyone's on a platform now like
and you know people knew about my life
or had a say in it in that time so I
grew up like that on telly
his dad was Villa players adopted for
Villa and Sheffield Wednesday so he had
that sort of level of famine in a weird
way as well so there was lords of
similarities and we just got on I mean
he will he would have said there's a
weird saying that no but he would have
said that I pulled him in his mind he's
read the game even if you at the game
yeah I've read it as well and so he read
the game and so he was like basically on
this job this is how this is how he got
into my head he someone went it was
giving cuddles out on the boss walk
Cringer I like he's giving cuddles out
to the girls right you do right so he
didn't cuddle me right right and so
someone went
why didn't you could hardly any went and
I went don't cut him me I ain't that
tactile like he didn't say you could
cuddle me like oh well like defensive
about it and then he didn't and I've sat
there and in my mind probably because of
my eagle I'd have been like why didn't
you come into the corner so kind of a
very good excellent work and so yeah so
we went I moved to confer to the next
day I left the person I was worth and
moved to Coventry later next day I went
back I ain't about the cheatin life I
went back and broke up and that was a
bad Commissioner I broke up with him and
went to Coventry didn't tell anyone for
a better workout if this is the real
deal or what and we just kind of went if
it if it's quite a flake we just suck it
always be straight with each other
League to see it [__] I'm not into it
anymore
and we pretty much didn't leave each
other side since about a week later we
got a rail in the house for me to hang
my clothes on that's when we knew it was
this is serious
[Music]
we just like we never like jokes aside
we like his may it started calling us
Rolly his name was Ross and we just got
called Rolly because we just used to pop
out together like we used to just say
like those that play at gather stay
together like have a laugh and like we
saw for me like you know we spent before
Rus was diagnosed we spent a lot of time
together just parting around both
self-employed did what we want he hides
housing in the property and then his own
football team we're business and so we
just used to pop around together I do
you know drinking cops Athenian biscuits
and another laughs and then became
parents and that was all in a new
journey and then when he was diagnosed
which would have been about four years
ago and then you know it hit us like a
ton of bricks but we he still dealt with
it in a really matter-of-fact way like I
said to you earlier Ross was on the
autistic spectrum anyway so it was black
and white I'm dead I'm alive there was
no bollocks about it there was no
feeling sorry for himself and not made
it easier on everybody else around
because he didn't he just got on with it
and you didn't hide it from the kids
either from what I've seen the girls
were really young when he was diagnosed
so Texas was just one when he was
diagnosed
I'm obviously there was no like
explanation to her Brooke knew but it
was it wasn't anything tangible because
she was like really young and so brain
cancer was a word but Ross was an L like
that sounds a weird thing to say you
know you got a scar on his head but to
them he was just dad with a scar and he
said it wasn't ill and and even like
when people when he died you know people
mean well and they say the things the
cliched stuff that they say and I least
he's not in pain and I'm like he wasn't
in pain like we're talking like we were
in the Caribbean and May this year and
within a month he was dead like it
wasn't like a long process he was until
we were we were in the Caribbean having
a holiday and normal holiday and he came
back two days later had a seizure and
went downhill from there so there was in
lots of ways you know like when we look
you talk right I feel lucky like his
cancer was bad from the start like he
would fully say
it's just like it's like you'd say like
well I should be dead
i Sony crews doctors have worked a
little bit overnight it's like I
shouldn't be here like it was never any
like we understood how serious it was
and obviously you hope that it's not
gonna be the case and you know we tried
all the stuff and yes we tried
county-based before people comment
underneath yawn and you know we tried
everything and it wasn't enough
unfortunately you know sometimes it's
just not enough and but you know we had
and we were very clear with the kids but
the kids didn't really get it until
really near the end like the last year
so August yeah August last year he had
his second brain surgery we had to
explain to them then what was going on
because obviously we didn't know whether
he would survive that and we sort of
talked through them but again it's it
was weird three days I'm super in
surgery
he was wallpaper in Texas his bedroom
you know like he didn't give a [__] he
had bandages I mean he wasn't supposed
to be but it was the hardest block of
like mentally the strongest blog and not
like a stiff upper lip or anything like
that just like pure I'll do it the [__]
I want like on every level and so the
kids didn't really see it it wasn't
really until I had to say dad's gonna
die that they really understood it which
is brutal but that's how it was like it
it was quick it a lot was four years
that the end was really quick for them
well you do feel lucky then like I
honestly genuinely people will look at
my life and they'll put that one filter
on it and they'll think and I get it
because if somebody who taught me my
story I'd go [__] like you've been
through some [__] like I'm not stupid
enough to not see that I don't feel like
a victim I don't feel sorry for myself
like not for one bit like I've got nice
things I've got a nice life I've got
opportunity I've got money in the bank
I've got a brain in my head that can
create stuff like I've got two kids I
might not have had any of that you know
like when Russ was diagnosed I remember
sitting and I think I've mentioned this
in a video before but I remember sitting
in the hospital and we were waiting for
him to be scanned
how bad [__] was in case it was anywhere
else and we both sat there and we were
like and Russ always used to say like
just make good decisions make good
decisions and knife stop me don't make
[__] decisions like think about what
you're doing in that and like you know
don't get you're selling debt and
[__] take too many drugs and don't
[__] you life or like just make good
decisions sounds obvious are so many
people's [__] struggle without like
serious used to say like if you want to
do it stop [__] talking about doing
it and just do it and you know like a
mother still a proper like straight and
we sat there and we just went look we've
done enough of our lives that we've got
on top of our lives enough that if we
sit here now you know we've got kids
first of all that wouldn't have been an
option we've got kids with we've got
property we'll be cool if we sit you
haven't do [__] off for a year we'll be
alright
financially and and all that it would
still be alright I mean obviously
weren't going to do that but we'd have
been alright and that was a really
really amazing position to be in and I
never you know there's people aren't at
all in that position in that
circumstance and it just piles on the
[__] that could happen to any of us at
any time and it will and if you've got
other stuff on top of that it's hard to
court with I mean I can't imagine
because we didn't have to weed we're
done enough to sort of keep on top of
our lives before that it's a few lucky
you know like I really do like brain
keeps going back to the fact that you
had that holiday just before yeah
obviously took a turn for the worst and
I think myself got like how many people
would love to have heard that but you
knew if they loved one before that
happened do you look back at that
holiday it's hard to actually I find it
hard to look at the falls out cuz it
feels like yesterday it feels in no time
it wasn't and that holiday our friends
and my husband's mom's friend lives out
in Turks and Caicos and she invited us
out and it's really weird because I
think and I'm not trying to like make
out like there's some kind of psychic
mess but I think there was something
intuitively in May that knew there was
something not right with us
even though there was no obvious signs
because I cancelled two events that I
was supposed to be doing to go at the
Caribbean I was supposed to be speaking
at a women
business in business event and I just
said look and I never do that it wasn't
I wasn't paid to do it but it was I
never canceled stuff and I was like just
we really need this holiday like it's a
really amazing holiday like we're being
given free pretty much it's gonna pay
for the flights and it'll be incredible
and Brooke my daughter was supposed to
be doing some TV thing as well and I
went you know what there's too much
going on like I think she needs time
with the family and let's just let's
knock it on the head and that was before
we went and he was on the holiday a
little bit more lethargic than normally
had a bit of a seizure on the plane
which not like a drop on the floor
seizure but he used to have these
seizures wherever he would like his
voice would certainly take his brain
wasn't connecting so he just starts
saying like weird stuff it was pretty
bad Spanish because on the plane there
they were terrible the British I was
were pretty bad you mean the the airline
the airline yeah what what what we have
about because he was having a seizure as
we were London right and I got off
because I could sense it I just used to
he had this weird like like it almost
like he was having a stroke look on his
face his mouth would drop a bit and I
was like Russia all right and then I
moved Texas out of the way in the the
asteroid came up which was like you need
some seat belt and I went no he's having
a seizure like I need to sit with him
and she went okay I actually went he's
having a seizure he's got brain cancer I
need to sit with him like I don't know
what's gonna happen now like you think
they've kind of be like what can we do
she went okay knows life [__] it was
really weird so like I you know but on
the holiday itself he was really good
and we had a nice holiday we you know
the a friend that lives out there was
amazing and you know she paid for us to
call for like five-star meal and they
took the kids from us and we actually
had a really amazing time and coming
back it was Ross's 32nd birthday on the
Thursday on the weddings day we were sat
me and the girls and we were right in 32
reasons why we love Ross why we love dad
and there as I'm right in this I mean
the poignancy of this is like not lost
are they like we were right in that and
I looked over and he was sort of
chattering and I thought it's the only
form of someone I'm gonna fall oh my god
he's not he's having a seizure and the
girls were obviously there and the kids
are amazing like they're just they knew
that when dad has a seizure we had we
had already set out rules for what
happens and was to go on get gone get
the neighbors they go they take
themselves to the neighbor's house so I
went broke daddy's having a seizure go
next door so she went next door and got
the neighbors and the kid the kids were
out the waist they didn't say it but it
was from and like he didn't from me
personally that's when we lost Ross like
for everyone else they can pretend it
was easier for them to pretend for
longer but he was brain damaged from
there and like he wasn't you know he was
at the start it was almost funny because
he was saying weird stuff like the next
day was going I'm going to London today
on ER for squishy milkshakes and I was
like nah me and the nurses were like is
he going to London I was like no he's
not going to London so for everyone else
around they could pretend for you know a
good few weeks before he actually went
really bad but for me it was like you
know like even the hospice you know a
lot of people go back to hospices and as
much as it it was as good an experience
as a hospice can be I have no emotional
attachment to that Hospice in terms of
Ross in my mind Ross didn't go in the
hospice like it was a version of Ross
but it wasn't Ross and so that's hard
for me I'm trying to understand because
I've got very limited knowledge on what
it's like actually experience being
around somebody who's having these
problems for the way you're describing
them it's almost like the brains of
disconnects a bit from the from the
person yeah I think it's like it's
almost like like dementia so late you
bits of the brain are starting to go and
for me when we told the girls it was
really important for me to do it when we
did and I'm so allowed I
dead because he was still late lucid
enough to be able to kind of be okay he
could have a weekly I could have said
that and he could have said sandwiches
embarked like I can't that could have
happened because there was not like his
brain was just malfunctioning basically
by the end there was lots of tumors or
all around his brain and so it was just
affecting areas you couldn't anticipate
and so yeah it was just it was a weird
thing I because I had gone from like
when I met Ross like he was so on the
ball like he's the most like he's the
person that you would rely on the moss
for anything like if he needed something
done you'd get Ross to do it and he's an
organized a so it was a really weird
thing for me to suddenly not trust his
judgment on anything because at the
start he was still talking and you know
he thought he was fine and the doctors
had to say Ross I'm really sorry but
you're not going to be saying anything
that's right from now and and at the
start I mean for him
imagine that imagine someone saying to
you you can no longer trust your own
brain because you still think you're
right eating and so the start for me
when he came out of the hospital
initially was really hard because I knew
that he was like this walking all over
the place and yet he wanted to go
upstairs and our stairs are like badly
steep and I was like rush you can't go
upstairs may like you can't and he was
like why can't I go upstairs I can go
upstairs and then he'd get upstairs and
like you know I'm like seven stone and
something and like
I'm a miniature person like as hard as I
think I am in my head that's just the
Jordy of may it it I'm not gonna be able
to you know lift a dead weight which is
what I was doing in the end like in fact
when he came back and before we went
into the hospice and I was the one
looking after him and we had carers but
you know they were like coming in a
couple of times a day making cups at
8:00 and I just hated every second of it
quite frankly because I just was like
having slaves and just like they
couldn't do anything to help brass and
you know I was physically having to lift
Ross like being on the bed Paulina more
panic luck she having to move him he was
a very big blow yeah only six floors and
you know I mean he went he was a skinny
lad but he he was tall one at all and
mercifully must've made like it doesn't
you know it's hard enough me lift and
the kids never made a man yeah and when
I talk when the nurse came out on the
day before we were in the hospice and I
was explaining what I was doing the
nurse burst into tears and she was like
this is ridiculous like I'm I'm we're
waiting for a disaster to happen like
you're gonna get hurt he's gonna get
hurt and and you know he wouldn't let
anybody else near him because um I was
the one that he trusted to be near him
and to help him in so it was just that
being a hall was the hardest mind
because it was just I mean mean Ross
like were the most open couple in the
world like there was not a thing that I
hadn't you know what if I were not
bothered by anything
yeah but we're the moss to open couple
and everything and not bothered about
anything but there's a difference when
someone needs you to do something and
someone messing about and joking and and
suddenly you doing stuff like I mean
used to joke I mean this is how just
like awful he would be about stuff he
there was no boundaries on stuff like he
was talking about mutineers they're late
when he was like first diagnosed late
just kill me off on the way to his
second surgery he went Smee I just
and this stuck in my head and nothing
I've mentioned this in videos before but
he just went I just if I'm like [__]
after this like this surgery they just
kill me like take me somewhere and kill
me some people couldn't I mean it don't
know you're honest and that's the worst
thing it's not a nice thing to hear but
I know like how honest he was and he
said to me I just don't want you [__]
feeding me yogurt I don't want that
and in the hospice us feeding him yoga
and for me like you know as much as I'd
be like it's kind of funny because Ross
would laugh at it I'm like I found that
hard and the doctors had to say it to me
because I said that's them and they were
like but it's not this is a different
version of Ross now Ross just needs you
to do what you got to do like he doesn't
need you to be what you were for him
before and that was different that was
but he would be ruthless on all of that
like he wouldn't you know he would say
to me like when he was fine he'd be like
he'd like you'd be lying in bed maybe
like I put my socks on for me put my
pants off for me this is what you're
gonna have to do and I'm fogged like and
we would talk about that as if people
like just lifts me up but now if we like
doing it as a job it's big difference
when someone's laid for as like
brutalist our conversations would be and
to be honest I don't think there's many
people that could stomach living with
someone with autism who's gone through
that because there was no boundaries to
like what they will say you know his mom
bless us like the loveliest woman in the
world hard for you you know hard for a
mom to hear the son say I'll be dead
soon it takes away a lot of your
decisions I guess as well because when
you've got your decision to joke about
it that's great if you have that
decision taken away so what was that
laughing you talk a lot about him
obviously what about you going through
them as a wife watching their husband
sort of lose what made him hmmm yeah I
think it was it was a real adjustment in
every stage like when he was first
diagnosed the biggest thing was the
drive and thing and suddenly our roles
reversed like overall roles were
different and that was hard because they
not that we had traditional roles
because we didn't but there was
definitely certain things like cars and
like DIY stuff and things like that that
he you know there was blocky stuff that
I wasn't up offered about and he would
do and then suddenly it's like I've got
to drive him about yeah and he hate that
was the biggest contentious thing in our
relationship in the end and you know
realistically like there were times when
he got in the car like I ain't gonna
stop him David not like
ain't gonna stop him doing that they got
what I had to realize is like from the
start I was trying to like go back
you've got to eat this and you've got to
do this and maybe you could do it this
way and you could do it that way and
they do how I would do it and I had to
realize that's not who losses and it
wasn't just my journey like it wasn't my
journey that big that was how and I had
to sort of let go of that of trying to
control it and go Ross will decide how
this runs and if he doesn't want to do
it
he doesn't have to direct when you're
describing this it's like it feels like
like a superhero who's lost his powers a
little bit like and in a way like you
haven't I sort of he's a normal person
now general I mean I'm not like because
he was from everything you described him
what I've watched in the videos like
he's pretty cool guy he had a lot about
him and then now all of a sudden you all
having to take the lead on a lot of
things it was like I mean for a long
time it was easy to like not know us I
mean other people around maybe saw me
filling gaps for him and there was death
in near the end weirdly because we were
we always said like when we met we were
both lone wolves who managed to live
with each other and get on they we were
so self-sufficient like I'm the most
independent person and so was he when we
lived in a house together it was like
I'm doing the washing you'll do it wrong
I'm doing the washing it was not the
normal I was like we had to learn to
allow each other to do stuff because we
were just so like self more these many
women around like those the loans I know
I'm do not alright
he had rules with the washer like
serious rules like one of the rules was
and they'll just impart this wisdom on
you because it's it's important socks
should never ever from beans and being
put on or taken off be more than a foot
away from each other oh wow the autism
coming up being a good rule I mean it
really helps if he like we used to join
it because of the autistic side like if
he was put in washing on their clothes
horse it would take him 45 minutes it'd
be perfection a big work for art and I
mean we talked about it like a week he
know like how bad it was like we'd
learnt we'd seen counselors about his
autism and so we tried to sort of work
through that for him because he was
diagnosed at 26 so it was it was late on
really late to be that we weren't really
the Arab or worry of like people being
noise it was just and cuz he wasn't
unconfident he was the opposite she make
no boundaries
hilarious funny is anything for me like
and I'd have to like pretend that I was
like bothered by it and play like
apologize for just like that you have me
being like Ross don't do that inside of
my foot he spoke keep doing it it's
really funny did you think he learned to
cover it up because a lot of people
autism sort of you and that's why a lot
of you know we used to say like he it
was good for him to go out with an actor
because they obviously act as a pretty
much we have less boundaries and we're
so like play your roles we play roles
and and and he had a script and like we
used to joke about it because there
would be certain things conversations
that we repeated on loop and like just
scheduling jokes and stuff but we would
repeat and if I had said it differently
to go mmm you're saying that different
can you just do it how are you supposed
to do it
and then we'll be fine about it
then in a weird like way that sort of
backfires on me now because wherever we
used to gone wherever I go where we
would be till which was pretty much
everywhere but like certain like going
to Ikea and I did a video about this
every week and I know what he would say
every stage I know going into Newcastle
I know that had gone across the time
bridge he'd be going oh we're in the
tune and aslo should I cross the time
bridge every time I might have heard
that before say like so the last time
but he said that last time but he would
see it like everything would be on on
loop so yeah I mean definitely he sort
of mask dude he must it with confidence
and bravado and like being the one that
said the harsh I joke quicker and so
people couldn't really like they just it
was just our Ross he's just like he's
rude like he just says the wrong thing
like but then once we actually when he
was diagnosed he was really relieved
because he was like see told you there
was something but like that didn't make
any difference it just meant that we I
just learned to speak autistic language
which makes it weird now because I'm
people to be like how long you gonna be
in I'll be like approximately 7 and a
half minutes and they'll be like okay
there's a 10 no like yeah but if I'd
said that to Ross it would be like 10
minutes precisely then and I'm like no
but it's weird I just learned to speak
like that but I think as his brain
started to deteriorate as he got ill
near the end even really in the last
yeah I could probably see it if I look
back it's just that I was close enough
to it that I probably didn't notice it
as much
there was definitely like the signs that
the autistic traits got worse so the the
level of control in his environment got
worse and obviously now looking back
that was obviously the tumor drawing and
kind of pushing on areas and affecting
things as well so he started to want me
there or like all of the time needed to
be rounded alloy we would joke about him
because we were used to being together
actually looking at that now there was a
level of him needing me to be there like
to sort of quarks and through the day I
got just used to be I mean we were lucky
in the fact that our work meant that we
could do that and we could just be
together in
you know now that he's not here I'm glad
that we had that time but there was
definitely that sort of sight of me
having to be around all the time to just
go come on I say come on flower let's
get moving
would you so would you share do you
think he shared a lot of that with you
the emotional side of losing that
function or it was a you we're not that
kind of couple we talked about and it's
not a conversation I don't think we we
didn't have and as much as this is hard
for people to understand he wasn't sad
at all about it it's really a weird
thing but when me and Russ met he used
to say I'll be dead by the time three
that's a weird thing to say yeah but it
was like probably from lb he used to say
it's him all the time I'm Jewish funeral
who's the snap I'm June 1 of that like
he just saw life scientifically like you
know just evolution [__] matter
of facts like at his funeral the funeral
was pretty amazing in the woman it was
like a watcher polymer human that's a
humanist that's one humanist funeral and
we you know we really like had his story
in it and it was so like true like
everything was just about like it was
matter of fact and I think there was a
bit in the funeral where she said I'm -
Cartman be exactly what it was but she
was saying you know for us there was no
more reason for him to have cancer then
a leaf that falls off the tree being the
leaf that falls off the tree and that is
it and we saw life like that and so for
me you know Russ dying in the hospice
it's really a weird way cuz I don't have
God I don't believe any of that stuff I
believe in science and I believe an
energy that cuz it's not really
something you can't not believe it but
like I never had that attachment to
Ross's body in the same way that people
might so for me it was it was like
science like I was like I detached from
Ross being that the person that I was
sort of beading and by the end just his
body like as matter of fact as that is
and it's hard for people to understand I
detach from that and and allow that I'd
lost Ross a month ago and that this was
his body doing what bodies are supposed
to do in breaking down and did you
all of us have lost someone close to us
but I think some people deal with grief
in that way don't they
how was was that the way to everyone
around him approach that because that's
not always my experience with people who
grew the Ritz a real true the tears I
think it's yes it's a way of coping no
way yeah I think so on and I was also
advised by people who think like me to
detach I got actively detached from that
it wasn't because it emotionally you
don't need like we sort of said this in
the way ever you don't need to feel all
the feels all of the time you don't have
to put yourself through that and this is
something that ice before now is that
like it's not about being wait like not
in touch with your emotions it's just
that self-preservation in some instances
you need to detach from Telsey some
people feel the need after a death I
think to to press the self-destruct
button and I've done that I've been in
my time and I realize that why am I
doing this as a tribute act to the fact
that how much this person Linda was I
don't have to destroy me life to prove
to everyone in myself how much I love
the person there is a performative side
to it and that's a to grief isn't that's
the weird thing
I mean we I'm not like trying to put
this on myself but because we were
really together as a close-knit family
in the hospice I got and and because
people respected how mean was were
together and and knew how close we were
and knew that like I knew Ross like
inside out and I knew what he would
think it was almost like people would
come to me and say but what would Ross
think about this and I would say like I
know what us would think about it
because we've spoke endlessly about life
and death and what your ask is maybe
that question I'm not asking you that
question
yeah is the answer because I [__]
know yeah that's what I mean I mean that
is it like and I think everyone sort of
I think when I started to talk about the
stuff that I believe in like a kind of I
think it helped to people around me
because they could have went into what
you think we've supposed to be like that
the performative aspect to it and I
definitely think there is that for some
people that they feel they need to be
like wailing and wearing a black veil
and and staufen I've seen people at
funerals before after
you barely even like the least want to
grieve the most if you're a num night
it's not like I think there was a point
and I sat and I you know I do
self-developed myself I you know like
I'm late for port to myself and I sat
there and I thought I was because there
was so much in the press about what was
happening and you know I know I'd put
myself out there that's that's on me but
there was so much like eyes on me what's
she gonna do next what's gonna happen
next that I sat and I was sort of
second-guessing myself a little bit and
I thought to sit there and think you
don't live your life the same as anybody
else in any aspect there's not a thing
that you do that is normal like sort of
normal way of working nan way of living
why the [__] do you think you're going
to do this any like the same as
everybody else and I had to sit there I
think just [__] do it how you want to
do it like put your [__] makeup on
get dressed
meditate [__] put your videos out
laugh do what you need to do because I
know that rocks would have done the same
and that's just the way I thought of it
and I think that sort of attitude from
me helped others around me to sort of
allow them off the hook like and not
late don't cry because I cried as well
openly oh yeah you've got to take
control of the situation at some point
and you just happen to do it pry it who
was to his death which is unusual but as
you see and I back this up because I've
watched your videos now watch them as
you awaken them that that was one thing
that hit me is you had I don't know if
the touch is the right word but you'd
accepted what was about to happen for
sure and that's probably why you were so
much more together and your mind was so
mapped out and clear of you you were
saying things which blew me away like
you know we talk about the children and
you said at one point we are going to be
better people for this experience and
I'm not saying that that means that
we're going to be rainbows and sunshine
because at every milestone in your
children's lives there's also always
going to be that little gray cloud where
were thing and be nicer if dad was here
but we are going to be bad people for
this because we're going to learn to
appreciate each other what's a writer
and I just thought what a deep
for words thinking thing that was to say
in the midst of pain and suffering I
think we'd all like I mean we Ross said
it when before surgery the second time
and he said I mean we had been together
nine years and he went it wont seaman
off like it on paper that doesn't
reflect who we've been as a couple mmm
and I totally understand that it's
almost like and Ross's life was full
like really fall at 32 what he had done
and the experiences that he'd had I
don't mean like any big like [__]
Mountain Trek but he'd lived his life
and he Belle you need never didn't do it
night five he didn't what the [__] he
wanted every day because he'd grafted
his arse off at the start to be able to
do that and he took some risks and and
he did some stuff and he used to say to
me and we actually put it on the the
funeral cause I said just tell him I was
alright tell him I was a good bloke like
I was happy I enjoyed my life he said in
the last year he said categorically to
me when I die I'm happy I'm happy with
what I've done I've done what I wanted
to do and I don't think at thirty too
many people could say that I don't think
many people could be and so for me that
gives me a level of comfort scored you
know what sometimes people just call me
out and they've got they do that thing
and that's it there's no more than that
they don't get that full life but what
we had as a couple in that short time
and and we appreciated it like we used
to say like I'd Bank moments I like in
my head I would like I would actually be
a thing I would think about and it
wouldn't be the big moments it wouldn't
be the big party or the big event it
would be sat watching telly and I just
for a minute I would just take myself
out of it and think we might not get
this again and now that might seem like
a horrible thought and should be
thinking hopefully all the time but I
would just acknowledge how [__] lucky
I was to have it in the moment I knew
that was like a petrol tank like you're
almost like filling up for later and
then you're gonna use that to sort of
travel off of general
yeah that makes sense I've heard stuff
like I've done those things before as
well just kind of and I would take I
mean I you know you if you followed me
on Instagram or whatever you do follow
me on instagram don't ya Holly Matthews
84 just links are in the description all
of this sauce in the description by the
way that's a little net check out if you
follow me on that and I take pictures of
everything in and I'm glad and I did it
purposefully like there was Mormons I
talk that were nondescript moments but
there weren't nondescript to me there
were like things like it could be my you
know the kids paint in the walls of the
house with Ross and there was part of me
that understood that we might not get
that again and that at any stage we
might not have Ross and so I would take
for graph of it and think the girls will
need this and even like when Ross was
dying near the end I took photographs
and honestly the four graphs I can I
can't look at now like because he was
not Ross and I can tell I can tell but
when the girls are older it would just
be a picture of them with dad smiling
and there doesn't matter it doesn't
matter what what my filter is on that
and I don't he was one of them yeah and
you know I mean there was a time two
weeks before Ross died in the hospitai
stopped the girls coming in because it
was too much and I couldn't you know
there's they just didn't need to see it
they don't you see there was a moment
you described to me on the way in where
you said you're on the way to boots and
he had to buy you know nappies fur and
you were like what the [__] am i doing
and yeah and yeah yeah odd that was one
of your hardest moments by the songs
yeah and I haven't put that it was I
made a video of it and I said to you
I've made videos that I didn't haven't
put out and I might at some point but I
made them for myself to make sense of it
at some point in how the darkest moments
and again it was probably a level of
make or maybe the girls need this at
some point maybe someone else will make
sense of what they're going through with
this and I just wanted to put it out
there I didn't want it to be out there
then cuz I couldn't have dealt with
people seeing that at that time it I
don't need to bear everything but there
was a video that I made it was the night
before he went into the hospice and
suddenly he suddenly became incontinent
and that wasn't something that had
happened suddenly it happened
one night and it was quite late and I
was on my own and the kids were asleep
and I was like like I can't lift him
like I was actually like fully having to
lift him it was falling on me he's
pissing the bed and I was just like I
mean and I phoned his me and I said look
Jackie lives know like me or us like can
you come around please his best mate and
he came round and I said just need to go
any home vitamin a piece it was like the
last like 10 minutes of all the stork
laws I'm like dart and into boots and
I'm in the middle of boots buying
nappies and like thinking you would be
put on the bed or whatever and I sat in
the car afterwards it was raining sat in
the car it's dark I'm sitting there with
nappies and looking it like next where
we'd been you know the month of
previously buying house stuff and I'm
like what the [__] like what is
happening he Alec I'm sat here buying
nappies for my husband who's like
pissing and [__] the bed like what
like how was the whole human senses up
and the next day was like that I mean I
went back and got him sorted and stuff
and then the next day was the day when I
went I need some help like I can't I'm
not I'm not helping him e-every some
comfortable like a I'm not it's not like
Ross had never been been like oh I need
to be home when I die you're gonna
excitement just do what you need to do
like he didn't see it like that there
was no sort of nostalgic like I need to
be here and like you know there was
nothing like that and so I just thought
you know what if he's there he's gonna
be comfortable and I can actually be his
wife maybe for a week or so and that
kind of did happen because I didn't have
to change his nappy and have to wipe his
ass from I didn't have to try and get
him take tablets which became again an
issue in when he was still lucid enough
to argue with me you wouldn't take
tablets and they were like you needed to
take them and we'd spend most the day
maegor Massa please take tablet please
I couldn't get him to take them and it
was just a stress in it was really
distressing and so get him in hospice
even though you know he wasn't it was
there a month in it he became like
sleepy and then died it gave me at least
a week where I could at least maybe say
things even though I know it wasn't
fully him there was moments when he had
like a bit of him left and so we'd have
conversations and you know that was
enough for me to make peace with stuff
in my head I think just a sort of yeah
can you but he was like there when he
died and I was like yeah so the morning
of it been an amazing nurse that was
there all through the night and stuff
with me and and she'd been great and I'd
actually when we first came in I was
getting quite panicky because I didn't
know and and people might not get this
but I was googling what the stages of
death are like it's like what happens to
people's body like how does it break
down how am I gonna noise he's just
gonna I was asleep in the room with him
so they allowed me to stay over I was
there every night every second like
because I that I needed that like I
needed to be there like it for me it was
like that was important and so I'm lying
in the bed and I was thinking this was
like the first week a sequin and then
date the nurses kind of spoke to me and
said actually we know when people are
gonna die usually we kind of know when
it's gonna happen we can tell by their
breathe and we can tell by certain
things their body does certain things
and he's not quite there and I was like
okay let me sleep and then on the day
that he his breathing was but I mean he
hadn't eaten for two weeks I mean that
for me was hard because Ross wasn't a
big guy like and he got the biggest beer
like well put your beer to shame like it
and it was like massive and I kept
saying you [__] love it it's a face
or being a rock star and that actually
helped because we couldn't see how
skinny was to run is that was really
distressing because just watching
somebody starve to death like
and so it was really skinny and he was
just been asleep for about a week and a
half and it was just breathing and then
his breathing was just rattling and
death rattle they call it and he was
doing that and in the morning the nurse
I've been chatting with her for a bit
she'd been in the room for but half an
hour and she his mum was actually
staying at the hospice as well they had
these like flats and the nurse said I
think it's time to get mom I think not
sure but I think and then I formed Owen
got all over and then we formed his dad
and his sister and his brothers a
football alarm blares of Doncaster in it
his brother it was on the Saturday so it
was a football day although it was
preseason so it just had like he had one
game but we ran him I said like do you
want to be here or have you made peace
like and he was like on a play of 45
minutes I'll come off and halftime I'll
comment but I don't need to be there you
need kind of made peace with that and so
we were all there and in the morning
he talked what we thought were his life
his last breath and he starting it's
really weird cuz this they can sometimes
stop
looks like they've stopped breathing for
like a like a minute and you're like
that's it and then they take another
breath and you're like oh my god and so
he did that and the nurse rush me and we
got there in his monkey and I went I
think I think that might be it and then
he his mum kind of like did what moms do
and was like come on Ross and he
breathed again and then he took this one
last breath and then for the rest of the
day was just breathe and like normal so
we were like okay so maybe it's not it
yet and we're do that you know like sort
of gallows humor and that late where you
like start laughing about stupid stuff
the rest of the day because he's done
he's dad when after about one hour why
he went dr nuts isn't his moment i don't
know what you did there to bring him
back
yes I'm good all right Jesus humans like
taking the mick out of a corner the
Messiah for the rest of the day like I
mean that is messed up like but you need
that you got him and then when he died
we had actually gone out of the room for
the first time like for about a [__]
week and went to gone eat something and
his sister was sat next to him and then
suddenly the alarms went off and we are
only been out there about 10 minutes and
the nurses run me and we got in and he
basically talked about two or three
breaths as I was then we got there we
were all there and his sister afterwards
was like I just said I loved him just
think of killed him but you know we it
was I died I mean nice isn't the word
but it was it was what it was and by
then for me I just wanted it to be over
for him like I'm not gonna like for the
the weeks prior to that you know I think
I did say this it's a weird messed-up
headspace to be and that you're like
clinging to them wanting them to be
there but then equally like just let go
it's enough now like and at that end I
was you know just saying I guess you
know mom's instinct moms wanna go and I
can't understand his mom's journey
because it's too painful for me to even
as a mom even get into that headspace
because that's your child it's not the
right order of things isn't supposed to
help in this it's not supposed to happen
that way and so I can't even contemplate
that but you know as a mom she's like
saying what mom say you know just don't
go and I was saying it's enough like
it's okay you can go on out like and you
know it it was just a weird thing
because it was just a nothing thing I
got I know that sounds a weird thing but
it was just buy it because it as in some
people would imagine it would be like
the movie moment whereas the reality is
a lot more normal yeah and then it's
like I mean we it sounds a strange thing
I guess but on the day I packed all my
bags all because I didn't want to do
that
I didn't want to be like packing stuff
up like as if like let's take a picture
oh yeah sent so much stuff and like I
didn't want to be like doing that then
so I did it early on and got everything
out felony so I didn't have to be like
it just as a weird thing would be never
month like would live there there was
stuff there and it was like clearing his
stuff up and and and doing that was just
weird so we did it all before and then
yeah then they just kind of said to you
like what you know what you wanted to be
wearing and stuff and like and he had a
you already had a chef Wednesday shirt
on and I was like like it's weird I got
I detached from that being Ross I mean
even at the funeral and stuff like you
know people it's kind of weird isn't it
in our culture we put so much scope on
their body and it's like that's not who
they are like to me that's not who they
are it's just the vessel that's what at
me when I first seen a dead body I was
always like wow like this isn't the real
person actually and but then it leads
you to sort of question things in the
head of dispiriting system because it
and I know we could talk about this for
I was but for me this is where I felt
that was like God it really does feel
like that the Spirit has left the body
like we're just just that energy cause
that guy's like they're just thus that
they're not they're like at it was where
like talking to the girls but and I'm so
glad that we spoke about a lot of like
life-and-death stuff before I mean
Disney opens up that conversation
because there's like death and Disney
and I'm parents die and Disney films
really dark it's so dark
I'm so like the kids have always sort of
spoken about that stuff and I'm really
glad that they knew I mean the kids knew
I didn't believe in God I couldn't
[__] them and say that afterwards
and but if they had said to me I believe
dad was to have another went with it but
what Brooke said and it's like the most
poignant thing ever
she just said and she said this
initially not with Ross with my gamma
died at the beginning of the air and it
was almost like a precursor to what
might happen and I kind of like knew
that that this might be you know
therefore this is their first experience
of death and she said I said what do you
think happens there was ask the girl
stuff and I'm like what do you think
happens on when people die and Brooke
just said look sick she said I just
think that when people die their love
that's in them just goes into all the
people that are left
and they just live on in the loaf and I
was like that's pretty nice thing to say
like I bet you a chocolate was [__] kill
me the kids just be like she said she
said this was again it was it was a jazz
or but we year and a half ago evident
Texas just said mom when people die in
taxi was four three maybe at the time
she just went when people died where
does the love go
she said lately I was like oh my god
like [__] and I I mean kids kids just
like they say exactly what they think
and they've I mean that's that cuts the
crap in itself because I can't lie like
I'm not gonna lie to kids and I've
always promised I would never lie to
them about this stuff like I will be
completely honest in the best way that I
can't but they've trusted me with out
you know when Russ went into the hospice
said mom woods I'd be coming home and I
said naw darlin and she said so will he
die in here and I said yeah he will and
then two days before he died she said
she rang me she Skyped me and she went
mom I really really miss ya like I mean
for them it was like I hadn't been there
either
they were been with my sister or with
Ross's dad or and she said I really
really miss you but I know that when you
come home it means that dad's dead
doesn't it and I said yeah it does and
actually as brutal as that was when I
did have to come home and tell them
walking through the door I mean I spoke
to and I've talked about this but I
spoke to Jeff bridge yeah Jade goodies
and all right now I spoke to him
initially when I was gonna tell the
girls and I got his sort of thoughts I
mean I didn't know I don't know Jeff
before we'd met some sure years ago but
because he talks about grief had
followed him on Twitter and he does life
coaching and stuff so I'd kind of seen
what he was talking about and we'd maybe
tweeted back and forth and then he just
said let me give you a call when I was
in the hospital and we spoke and then on
the day I was telling the girls that he
died he just kind of we spoke proved
like before that and he just said make
it a special day
they said make it you know if you can
get balloons if you can get use like
make it something that it's not
this frightening thing and I told them
we had best we had a cry weird biscuits
and then we sat down and we said she
look said can I can we draw some
pictures of daddy and I said let's do
that
and so we've got all the crafts and arts
out and we do pictures and we just got
on with it and you know it was that's
kids way of dealing with it and for me
like children's drawings are really
telling of how they feel and so Brooke
had drawn all the family everybody like
and it was all brightly colored which
again is a good sign drawings it was all
positive and every was smiling and she
drawn Ross but Ross was just slightly
away from everybody and I think that's
and I've kept that because I think at
some point she'll look at that and
understand that was like directly after
what happened one video you made
recently was titled my door I told me
she hates me and the Anna I thought were
at that stage now because obviously yeah
they go through that but when you were
talking I could tell it hurt you a
little bit but uh but you rationalized
that perfectly but what just for people
who haven't seen you know what was that
like basically I mean again Jeff brazier
had said to me they'll say things like
that and I guess that's all protecting
me a little bit I knew that would come
off I mean kids say it anyway in sort of
six seven year old kids are starting to
get that stage I mean I remember when
Brooke was like 4 and she said to me one
day I hate you I want another mommy no I
want another mother she said my went
alright that's really formal
I've collected all the cereal package
yeah well it's you know this ain't no
fairy tale this yeah daughters and the
mothers for a start and not notorious
for that type of talk and I left home
many times March so dramatic yeah and
then left it they didn't even notice
yeah I'm just I'm the garden
yeah they can always see you that's what
you don't know is when you are leaving
home little stick in his back Oh
dramatic and like ya know she and I mean
Brooke had we've actually turned a
corner in the last we we still have it
but I mean some of its to normal kids
stuff in Italy it's kind of me
recognizing when it's frustration
because of things I mean it's not just
directly like alright Russ's dad died
but everything's changed for the girls
they moved schools we bought a new house
we got a new car cuz we our car was a
disability it was a Moute ability
vehicles right to give that a straight
back like and then buy another car I
mean Donovan I don't feel sorry for
myself I got another car that's like
Western world problems I'm not I'm I'm
it is what it is one of those things but
for the girls it was like everything
changed which has been good and lots of
ways because it's not ever pretend in
their life is the same but also that's
really unsettling and so this it's not
just dad's not here it's everything's
unsettled and yeah so the day that
Brooke was I mean she's still I mean yes
the other day she said that means you go
mad at me for telling you this because
it is she about don't tell anyone me she
doesn't watch watch this no yes once
right Marty sure yeah why do you wear
that what would you have in mind
no no yes or she in the other dish was
like one day I'm gonna bite you and I'm
gonna kick you and that's it that's
gonna happen and I hate you no way
alright okay well I always say there's
consequences to your actions so do what
you gotta do do you think I am too by
many senses
you bite me and no be consequences
beyond this it's unusual Oh cause
normally the mother has bigger boobs but
what is nice about that is also they're
two girls who have lost a dad and I know
other people lost her dad to cancer and
they found that particularly painful
because it was later on in their life
are you glad in a way that they lost
their father when they were quite young
so it becomes a bit more normal
I guess there is an element of that I
guess I mean I suppose there's always
that and I guess it may be me important
my own thoughts and it but you start
thinking about the future and you start
think you know they won't have this with
him but they try not to think that
because they just think well then that's
their reality you know that is what it
is like I can't change that
about what's happened and I mean they've
both dealt with it in different ways and
they were very close to vacillate Ross
always wanted girls like it wasn't like
he wanted boys he always wanted girls to
be fair he did used to say it girls look
after you later in life and that wasn't
the case for him but do these sisters or
anything yeah he's a brother and a
sister I saw his brother is a young I
mean it's it's very very hard for his
brother because for it
Ross was the man about the family like
he was like in control of stuff probably
too much for them comes across when
available and he was like you know he
looked after them he did and for its
brother it was almost like a father
figure to him was a mentor like my teas
a darling and he all laugh at me when he
watches this but he is a darling we you
know sometimes footballers aren't the
brightest lovey my big brother jaded him
so Ross would tell him off all of the
time and so I think actually it's weird
his Grouper me it's like where I'm in a
makes me sound like such a lad but I'm
in a lads group chat on water from when
Ross was there but the lads are all like
one of the things that they miss the
most is being told off they're like you
know one of his mates posted in the
group chat the other day he'd put a
Facebook you know obviously Facebook
comes up with memory
and stuff and then there was a Facebook
where he'd be like really soft P about
his missus like gonna get married soon
or was all like that and raster just put
you soppy Kundalini and I absolutely
slammed him and he put this in the group
frames like who's gonna keep us in check
is gonna sort us now and his brother
particularly is feeling that you know
like after a football match he'd ring
Ross and Ross was absolutely dissect the
game and be like like absolutely slam
him on every phone Ross would pick his
football boots for him like you would do
it because Ross was a football boot nerd
like and football kid stuff and so all
of that for is younger probe on it
that's really broad like it was like
they were really close and so that's
really hard and and his sister in a
different way like they weren't close in
that way but not each other like so much
and he would you know it was a kind
person he wouldn't it would make food
for people and just bring it around just
give it like google cook so you would do
stuff like that and I think everybody's
just going through their own journey
with it I think at the minute and it's
just recognizing that everyone's journey
is different you know you know the
stages of grief and to me there isn't a
formula at all I think the way people
market ours if you just or you get a and
then you know then you work your way
don't as I do you'd be fine
but it obviously sometimes you'll jump
from day two but to be and in sometimes
you'll think I'm finished now I've
accepted it and then a week later are
you crying and IKEA as you said that
happen to you do you feel like there's a
stage that you're if you've got a
feeling of grief in general right now
it's a weird thing that got I feel like
everyone around me is waiting for me to
absolutely break down I feel it like
people like people have said things like
to my mother-in-law like does Holly cry
and she's like obviously but I don't
think I will
I'm not like not open so having a
breakdown like if it happens it happens
I have no judgment on that myself like
I'm perfectly entitled to a breakdown if
I want but I just I feel like I'm on top
of my own mindset enough that I just
don't think I well I'm allowing myself
to cry I'm not I'm forgiving myself when
I feel like I'm going into like
destruction being here and I'm like work
myself too hard I know that that's
happening I can see the signs of that
have
and I kind of keep in check and if if I
don't someone I'll be on my case like I
can usually tell before that's the case
but I feel like I'm probably you know
it's not it's gonna be those moments
it's gonna be those Christmas you know
that's coming up late you know it's
gonna be those and and then they'll be
done the next year again and it's just
gonna be I think it's the for me and we
said this I can't pretend Russ isn't
here like I can't pretend he's just
somewhere else like from the minute that
he died I didn't have my mate that like
you know we used to joke about a little
time with people but like we were
together all the time like we're just
and not like in some kind of way that we
actually enjoyed each other's company
like and I think that for other people
they can go they can just like and you
kind of said this as well like they can
their direct life isn't infected there's
a difference I think between the level
of love is different it's just for
people when someone you live with dies
and then someone you don't live with
dies it's different because you every
single second existence changes and it
doesn't mean it's any less important if
you don't live with them but it's just
it's harder to ignore it's so in your
face everyday like you would be doing
that stuff with them and suddenly I mean
it I think was a journalist asking me
this the day like you know what's the
hardest thing that's like it's not big
soft like it's it's normal everyday
stuff I'm like why am i doing this like
I don't I think I probably didn't
appreciate how much Ross did for me and
like in terms of mostly I'm gonna say
it's now because I'm cold now in it and
I'm always winching about the cold but
Ross used to keep me warm a lot like so
he would just walk up to me during the
day just periodically throughout the day
and either hand me a cup of tea or hot
water bottle because he would just
norther be called some pint like and
even like not like or he'd get in the
bed before me and like warm the bed up
for me just lying on my side like if I
was in the bath he would smile yes he
thinks yeah well you do that because you
take
I was actually thinking if if anything
ever happens to me one dude god forbid
I hope there's a woman saying I didn't
appreciate you if you are cold we can
close the windows opens really I'll just
you guys can see I'm always cold there
is a degree difference or something
between men and women so that's why they
always wonder hidden stuff always wanna
make it just cover me and fleece and it
set me alight I'm asleep with the window
oh yeah I bet you give off a lot of heat
he's gone over time radiator called
see what I mean she'll just all women
all women are always fighting
I know quite a lot though all women
touch their boyfriend as if they're the
only man in the world that's hot so all
women go wow your heart and the man
instead of going oh no all men are hot
they all go yeah no it's my thing I'm
actually a really warm yeah look before
with anger I'm the shittest Geordie in
the world it's been sadly well Geordie
girls are supposed to be they take the
cordon well there's two cities it will
three cities in the world where they go
out and they look like they're in the
air all this Liverpool Newcastle and
they yeah like they all just look I
would go out and not have a call on yeah
I accept that but inside I'm not
accepting being called yeah you
shouldn't lose civilization there's no
reason for that keep me warm yeah
genuinely I'm not just saying this for
one of the reason
I did say all right this is my first
fear meal yeah
err because you're a joy but you're not
just a job you actually like I think you
represent Newcastle women well Oh God
personally because I could have went for
a Geordie Shore show for example but I
don't know which one I think you're like
what the women I know the strong the
proper strong independent women of
Newcastle you know I did like because
I've lived like north south in middle
now so I feel like I've got kind of good
judge of like the culture of the UK and
I didn't realize when I went to London
and there is a massive cultural
difference there is mother I'm like a
fish oh no when I came you find this
without a doubt Jody's are very direct
people and we just like with like I mean
I went home not long gone and a pair of
furry boots on and I walked into as dad
just pulled up in in gossip I've pulled
into Asda and some girl went yeah I love
your boots they're lovely where'd you
get them from and I went my people like
I'm home 80 did you know like people
just say what they think and when I came
to London I found many people just
asking for change
people are people one on one but as a
collective there was like a feeling of
fear in London I didn't experience in
Newcastle and you know you speak
sweeping they're like what do you want
and why you said people used to say to
me alright calm down
right like why so angry I'm at I'm not
angry
yeah this is my normal temperament like
but it's there's a level of passion that
and this is gonna make a right cringe
but it there's a level of passion that
Jordi's have and also a full-on like
understanding of our history and
background like like no other people
like we love being Geordie so much like
we there is that like strength of like
who we are and we know our politics and
like we know where we've come from and I
don't know I guess it just gets brought
up in the generations and stuff but even
when I went to Coventry
they said I'd say it's people like so
what's good about Coventry and I'd be
like it's [__] all of them like
standardly would say that that is that I
mean that is probably what real love is
to me is moving to
for someone do you feel that because
when you first said I moved to Coventry
I thought you must have really liked him
do you know what I mean I didn't know
about no you know what Coventry sound
it's actually better when I got just
Coventry I went oh this isn't it's not
sexy name not sexy it's not a sexy place
in America I'll be adopting that for one
of their C's Carly what do you reckon to
be kilocycles the little bird Birmingham
Alabama they like move on Manchester oh
there is a Newcastle in America and in
Australia in Australia right ok so yeah
so yeah alright George but I'd recognize
Geordie girls now like there was a type
like and I did no [__] yeah I didn't
realize there was a tight like I sort of
people used to say are you dead feisty
was always a word you are feisty yeah
because when all of the boys the lads
you've got warm into your comments on
your next video more pets I know you
built the Hamlet so that's good I don't
I'm not sure there could be as weird as
some of the stuff that I guess that's
how all that I don't even mean like in
the rain give you we have a bit of an
issue with ITV shops walkers have you
been on this morning yeah okay you gonna
go on but you'd be gonna call sorry your
Suzy min on this the producers watch
this show really loose brilliant
brilliant the problem is you're positive
about men so yeah
no I just like people like oh yeah yeah
we've all been loose women um this
morning go you can be Philip and I'll be
okay is it sad as it is it Oh hard was a
horrible
there's your life really but and you go
yes good in their life you can see
there's someone in there going can you
make her cry make her cry yeah we need
the VT but then do you know what I think
I am that person that can cut that crap
like that's why I'm back on the rain on
Monday I'm back in there understand
really if I can learn a Monday yeah what
do they invited you back yes they're
coming to Coventry yeah we're doing it's
oh this is gonna sound like a fun week
but it's children childhood grief week
this week one week it's a great fun week
I'm Jeff Frazier yeah I'm doing
something with a charity called away
widowed and young again not a fun thing
it's not fun but it's actually a very
good charity and so we're doing like a
feature on that and then I'm back in
December and the reason I know for a
fact the reason I'm back is because I
cut the [__] and because I'm not just
giving them a talking point at I think
you know being growing up in on
television and stuff like that I don't
have any
I do not care at all I'm not like
nothing fazes may saw you know me going
on Silurian for some people that'd be
really daunting and they'd go into the
shadow me you know you're gonna deliver
know you're gonna give them not I just I
just kind of thought well it's just like
a chat in it but if I'm in if I'm a girl
sitting at home who's gone through
something similar then that's gonna make
me feel a lot better knowing that you
can come out on the other side of it
you're not I mean and you don't your
life just an end I need like I was
looking for that and I didn't really
find it very easily like I wanted like
it sat in hospice I was like I need to
see people that have thrived during [__]
stuff and I was like
search and I'm like why these people not
out there and actually something at me
isn't happening and you know I bang on
my channel I bang on about bang on about
mindset and positivity and Law of
Attraction stuff and I fully fully
believe all of it and and it's my life
like that's why my life is good because
I attract good stuff and it's not magic
I don't mean like who I'm attracting
stuff it's just because our brains can
only focus on good or bad stuff like if
you've put in [__] into your brain and
negative story your brain thinks us we
wouldn't you this before and on the way
is like you meet people all the time who
don't have that bad of a lives but in
their head they're the victim and then
they seem to just always bring
shitstorms on themselves and then they
wonder why is always me are you seen
your truth oh you talk about its
negative stuff and this is the thing
like I've never done that but I sat in
the hospice and I've had a few people be
like those people and I thought no
absolutely [__] not I'm not having it
and I thought I'm just I'm only gonna
allow in my space allowing my energy the
people that have got this [__] together
and that is it and I'm gonna attract
more of that and ass at and yes I am a
hippie wanker but meditated I meditated
in the garden of the hospice and I bet I
look like such a [__] and I don't care
because it meditation is a good thing
and a sight and I my meditation was on I
just want to focus on seeing that the
opportunity and the positive people and
I want to see those people and no
[__] half an hour later I've sat on
Instagram and a business coach friend of
mine was on there and I saw that she was
being featured in Forbes one Forbes on
the website and I was I up there Bassam
is and I commented she then inbox me and
when you've got it on this and she's
like I can hook you up and I was like
get me in Forbes like the [__] like yes
please
suddenly within 10 minutes I'm in a
group chat with this like mega time
coach mindset coach who were chatting I
don't really know what the situation is
with what she's doing she's writing a
book
and how she called how she did it on
female and entrepreneurs she's writing a
feature for Forbes and the Hoff it in
post
and people were paying for that
privilege of doing a package with her
and then being featured in Forbes and
stuff so I get in this group chat and we
know she she then Google's me looks at
my stuff comes back into the challenge
it's like look I know it usage in a way
where you are late I know you sat in
hospice and all what's going on and she
was they I lost my son to brain cancer
he was five I noticed until the end like
you can have everything for nothing like
it was about five grand package was like
you get it all like you'd be featured in
the books you'll be on Forbes often all
of the half and after I did that and as
people think I'm like that's just
[__] no it's not because I was open
enough and asking for that was looking
for that I was looking for that
conversation I could have went with a
negative mindset on Instagram [__]
life is [__] life is [__] and you know
what I've seen everyone's morning's day
said look I've seen more reasons to
think I was [__] I didn't and because of
that bad things have happened and so it
just depends how you look at stuff
doesn't really like perspective
absolutely I wondering how you plan on
you know when you're going forward now
raising the girls they call it babe mom
and dad I don't know if it's if it's
that exactly but trying to fill a big
role there's only one person I think all
for all I took as much as Russ was a
really hands-on dad there were certain
things that the majority of the
parenting would be done by me like their
day to day stop the the getting up in
the morning to stuff not that Ross was
it didn't pull his weight because he
really did like he cooked and cleaned
and did all that stuff but I think that
side of it but then there was always
that element of a blocks voice a
slightly stronger voice and you know not
Wayne Imams voice which is what it
becomes and
there is definitely that but what I did
because Russ has such a close group of
lad mates
I said to all the lads and they loved
the girls as well in their amazing
buncha lads and all really really have
been touched by what happened and found
it really difficult and I just said look
I said to the girls look if you need to
talk to our boy like then
and then all the last the lads are there
and if you want to form one of them
don't chat co and there has been a
couple of occasions when usually at
nighttime when I feel like maybe the
conversations on loop a little bear and
it's repetitive and it's not really
going anywhere I'll say to the girls
like join a boy chat like you want to do
you want to chat one of the lads and
they all say they'll say who they want
to chat to and they'll give him a call
in the lights of brilliant and you know
they'll they'll just chat there I mean
though they'll ask them stuff and and
they've got a lot of sort of blocks
around that can do that
I mean his Ross's brother Marty like you
know he absolutely as much as he's in
Doncaster Lake he can Skype them and
they know he's there and stuff and he
has said to me a couple of times you
know like when Brooke was sayin she
hated me we were going through like a
tougher time with Brooke a few weeks
back she was like you know if you need
me to come and step in because you know
physically there is that element as well
like you know Brooke six sometimes I got
dragged up the stairs
not like hurt now before anyone starts
falling people sort of surfaces or two
lives yeah but if I want to put Brooke
on the naughty step
oh joy you know and I've gotten she's
kicking and screaming physically it's
getting harder like there was things
like that way you have to you know but I
had a lot I think I always have in the
back of my mind what would what I do in
this instance and I know how we parented
we're kind of the last bastion of like
strict parenting like why I say goes and
I don't mean that in a hard way if you
can negotiate with me we've always we
always taught we've taught the kids to
negotiate but like you weren't
necessarily winning just like if you
donate your teen time you don't think
you're getting put in like it's stupid
stop but it's follow-through really and
I think you know that there will be
certain things that I will need a blocks
influence for like I will need to have
it's you know Russ's brother step in and
be that person for them because I'm not
a blog like I know that's where like one
but I'm not actually a blog that shows
how sensible you are because you do hear
some people who go I don't need a man
who you know I mean and like it's not
dynamics you can do without a man and
I'm not disputing that certainly [__]
helps to have speaking from experience
when I didn't have a dad growing up a
lot of the time when he was I would be
like for quite a lot of years I was a
total [__] and truthfully I could
have done with a good slap around the
head off me done completely to fear
full-blown just just and and I'm not
saying that that's what everyone needs
I'm just saying that's what I needed you
know I think you do not even I mean not
even that side of it like the discipline
side but just having a male figure out
there like having somebody that they can
have it like it's important like I'm not
a man hey I like what like we all bring
different things to the table like and I
think the girls definitely do need that
influence around I mean we speak about
Brooks been telling me diets and when
she's been she gets married she was like
you know she said when I get married to
mom like she's like I'm just she said
I'm a bit worried because I we've always
said to the girls weird is good like be
as weird as you need it be like don't be
like everyone else I mean we've had
across our old house we had written
across the wall I want to be anything
but ordinary please like painted on the
wall like I want the children to have
that influence in fact this week I don't
know if I said this on a video but and
this week Brooke was saying to me and we
were talking about Ross and I said she's
getting to that stage now where she's
embarrassed about herself like or like
what she's wearing and that like she's
like I think she fancies a boy at school
Rudi and so she's like she's good and so
she's going to school she's like all
like embarrass and I went what you
getting all about she's got a new scarf
on she's like you know people are
looking at me like she love this scarf
in the week and then she's in there
she's walking to school she's like was
this like and I'm like what you've been
like that for like and I'm walking in
like full-on fake for full floor-length
court like scarf and my hair is
noticeable yeah
definitely militant also say King scoffs
no they yeah that's me like late to be
noticed I just was like broke like do
you think mom cares about what people
think I couldn't carry their some
dresses for me I'm doing what I want I
said dad I said to be fair one you dad
would it be more embarrassing I said
I'll get more embarrassing but late dad
have been hellish embarrassing and just
like why am I only had big plans like he
had big plans for you you know like I
said he was gonna pick you up from
school and in his underpants on a
go-kart and she was like what I was like
yeah that's what he would do any he
would have done it as well probably had
been arrested and she went Smee I'm
someone that well you would have to do
it then because it's what dad played me
just as no what do you do that yeah
that's the way the website is obviously
then Rudy's just around the corner she's
like dude she said to me that should be
sound with it she was like what bye cuz
I said I try to play up she was playing
me like saying dad you'd wanted say like
as if I'm gonna back down like and
obviously the compare development it
means like oh you can say that you two
are definitely in then then because they
challenge time and so well it's fine I'm
not gonna do it now anyway when you're
in primary school it'd be when you're in
secondary school
that's when we can afford a go car yes
who save up that anger and the best punt
yeah exactly yeah she won't take
attorney she went I'll be fine mom sure
because I'll be much weirder by then and
I'll be fine I'll be like there's my mom
on the go cart and I went yeah being
arrested like putting over to the
secondary school in our knickers yeah go
cop no I know it's what you would have
wanted
that level of weirdness any kind of like
awkwardness like that rocks well I tell
you a story like recent and again this
is that gallows like humilating his
business partner went to his office at
the office needs to work quite late and
I eat and stuff because his business but
has a proper job as well and then it is
wrong me at ten o'clock is make jerky
ten o'clock at night and mycorrhizae
winger may answer the phone II was like
right just walked into the unit that's
where they work and M Ross is on the
table just like Ross's ashes are on the
table
yeah he's like was an anticipating that
didn't expect what he's like there's no
ambiguity like if you open the box it
says Ross Blair's cremated remains on
the box it's 10 o'clock at night it's
dark
yeah just leave you one is mama just put
them out the way a Lakers will be music
have you got any music at the end I'll
still put the same end boy such great
moments I don't know entrepreneurship
going failure all yeah good I don't
really know anything different so being
an actress I always kind of did other
stocks I never wanted to be a skint
actress and yeah because you look just
so people know you're in a lot of
popular British TV shows yes i starred
in the Geordie bond Micah growth which
some
started there as well so I started in 97
yeah so that would have been like my
prime like oh yeah I was little Emma
rhymes and she was a singer for a bit
and she was just really sweet and she
kind of the world they were all partying
for me like so I auditioned for
something else and then about six months
later they were partying for me and I
kind of just I was in it for seven years
and so grew up on telly so all laws or I
mean I'm just so bad that social media
was not around
although people like tweet me stuff and
they're like I'm look what I found a
picture gonna make have to like laugh
about make [__] get rid of it for
God's sake I can't yes I like I did that
and then I left to do singer scientist
or knee for a bit and top of the pump
eBay and all that stuff but that was
under a different name was under the
name summer Matthews so I flew Google
search YouTube search here summer
Matthews you'll find me singing it's
funny that is actually quite funny what
else I hate myself as a singer of
interest because some people I'm knockin
sing this song that I've released wasn't
really like it was a pop song and you're
sure that I can saying that because I'm
radio one sort of thing yes I do
somebody wrote on your Wikipedia that
you had like an Avril Lavigne sound it
was like a pop rock yeah sorry to shoot
a lot of our own stuff fair enough even
an Adele of the audiobook I don't think
there's anyone else in their music
industry over Jim Rice and storms engine
Oh in stories who we listen to a lot in
our car yeah storm see how cool anyone
like the
you're on the bill the bill all right
bill was my favorite one I'm not gonna
lie like I thought I was a fan of the
bill and I took the call for the
audition I've never been sought on my
game for an audition I've run my sister
I was like the bills come up and she was
like oh my god and guess what part and
she won't prostitute and I won't crack
it I've got to get this skinny yes fine
no I was a fat crackhead it was
Christmas in between filming so like I
saw that as a crackhead I'd be in
brilliant now sausages wrapped in bacon
I couldn't like I was like victus I'll
be fine and I'm really I like a chubby
crackhead but I look wrung it's great
like I went the day before doing the
scenes cuz obviously got the part he
actually went means like from your
headshot
I'd never have cast you but I went in
like I went on the tree I you took
actual crack I went in knocking rough
and he was like it sound like yes you've
got the pop she didn't even read Balak
she was in the pool sorry we were
expecting an actor oh yeah I was on the
tree by pretending like method in it
like people were moving seats because I
was like I was but the day before film
and I was like I need to look proper off
so me my sister I was living in Essex at
the time and we were down there and my
sister decided to get absolutely us all
drunk because I thought there now look
really rough right this seems like a
good idea in theory so we drunk really
dozen of vodka a bottle a liter of vodka
and we went through the street or the
stages of grief there's a stages of
drunk isn't there like there's like that
nice I'm just cool like this is fun like
oh then this like the sort of more
intense we're having a deeper meaning
for Venice the tears and the sanger and
then you phone people and you like leave
her messages and then you think you're
funny then you pass out whatever so this
was the level I was at and I was a bit
younger so I was like ridiculous I
barely drink now but then I did and the
next day I had to get up and go across
London to film for like about an 8
o'clock call and I got I was living in
like Loudon in Essex and
I had to get off at Stratford on the
centrality of vomit on the floor like it
wasn't that bad open that but and then I
went in and I was like filming and they
were all like this is great like this
just just keep going this way they were
like this is really good they didn't
know anything on come on I was probably
so drunk and the director was saying
stuff to me and there was that moment
when you'd like hung over I'm you like
the world's not really quite right it's
like bit forcing not sort of really
engaged with it and the director was
saying such mean I'm like did he say
like I was so bad I mean it looks good
like they were like this you really
really gone friend I with the cracker
like a lot of them don't really do it I
took it really seriously one episode for
the balance took it so serious that's
good but I loved it that was my favorite
part and then I went on to do Waterloo
Road and doctors and other stuff
casualty stuff like that I always play
rough parts or what's the Geordi like
they get me it's so I'm so I'm like
rough I mean I've become over the world
before Russell's diagnose was kind of
when I stopped doing audition and stuff
but I've got to Mon stripper mum
crackered like I was they were bringing
that was a hard for you except that
there's a woman cuz I know Mom not
because you sort of even though yeah
you're an actual mum like there's
something about women in age where
they're like oh god people see me as
long a mum age now was that was that
alright or did you handle oh I was
hiding because I was just I'd been
playing kids I was 24 before I played an
adult just cuz it looking small and
stuff like I just so played kids so it
was kind of nice to start playing
different roles and mom stripper man mom
stripper and crackheads mom strange did
you do it like did you actually have to
get your mind off on you with a stripper
I don't think I've done a nice
opportunity to naked or anything which
is all because we spoke into some others
like damn Portman the game of Thrones I
do he did stark bollock naked on stage
and the lot like you could be friends
with Judi crackhead and Game of Thrones
that'd be great I'm going to do
crossroads no no I've never seen it
people writing scripts T yeah would you
do it's not that I'm completely
comfortable with being naked that does
not bother me not on this show though
how did we get to this I don't know but
a mere confidence takumin I'm just
asking questions yeah and nothing in the
past out of Wednesday's yeah just as
anyone bothered hope nakedness by I'm
but I don't know now like I would walk
thing is being a girl right and you've
seen this in the industry now with
Weinstein and all this [__] that's
coming out there is definitely a level
of new directors come in and obviously
I've been in the industry a long time so
I've seen it and I think they're so
original and they'll script which is
basically their sexual fantasy and this
is like soul on like soft porn and
you're like you know I've been sent
stuff like even though Matt I'm not
actually haven't got an agent at the
minute but when my agent would send me
stuff and I'd be like like this is like
I'm not I'm cool with stuff like that
but I'm like is this doing anything for
me like am I gonna I don't think it does
and I don't think she needs to be naked
in that scene and actually it might
simply be Kate
it's just to trust us all right Holly
exactly yeah it makes sense like margot
robbie on their wolf of wallstreet like
that is tastefully done she's so hot and
like I get that and there was definitely
yes you need it and people are Nick in
life but actually it's almost like that
is the cutest and it's like the cryin
thing as well like when people are over
the top crying we don't actually do that
in real life necessarily and often it's
it's much sadder to see someone hold
back tears sometimes it's much sexier to
see that a little bit and then you like
[__] like you can your imagination finds
it ha ha but I've had like script sense
me in fact I was talking about this
because of all the sexual assault stuff
recently and I seen like this guy sent
me this script I don't audition for
something else and then he sent me a
part where there was a girl just having
sex in a swimming pool that wasn't in
the original script right and he long
after you actually you know that's the
funny thing is in the media industry
that and that's probably it's not
hilarious in any way but that's probably
why a lot of people get away with they
can send you that stuff and if you go
that's really good if you really want
the play you go and if you go that's
really sick they go it's just it's just
a script the indeterminacy everyone saw
tax havens thought or panic the comp I
mean the conversations you will have you
you're noise like there's no boundaries
with actors and people we don't really
have those elements and we'll talk about
stuff that normal people would be like
horrified at and so I think there's that
portman a lot ease
he is quite funny yeah thanks no but I
do think that because we have to like
play other people like we have to like
get into people's heads and so there
isn't those boundaries and then people
got a drama school and that's them for
adoption like people do weird stuff yeah
a normal school drama school in that
lake level
well I remember and it probably is on
YouTube my house live over I'd call Phil
man and no man Phil man great it just
like comedy so he's a great
is he journey as well no oh man Phil man
yeah that wouldn't should definitely one
with that and I just remember and I
can't get out of my head it's not that I
think about it or not feel but it's in
my head still that he was hoisted at one
point in a part in like drama school
hoisted into the air naked and I just
see just looking up and to see my
housemates bollocks his balls there this
is very pale we've all got is like a
guild hall is very cold during a term
heaters on the morning and just seeing
the Moyes it and just thinking I sort of
often in the active mode I take myself
out of what I'm doing I think what am i
doing like once I wasn't I was
pretending to be an otter in Epping
Forest which annoyed me because it
wasn't there terrain and I was being
asked to be on the floor in Epping
Forest like oh that's stupid
ace we do at least get the tummy and
that area right it wasn't stupid and
anyway I'm I'm sort of wriggling around
whiskers or he said no I'm just this is
just imagination stuff and I'm just
thinking for a minute I talked myself
out with this and I was like what are
you doing yes they say you get asked to
literally move a foot to the left and
you know sort of like I'm comfortable
here life present and no I'm not just
present really pretending we get a [__]
about Wes Brahms goals and then
obviously because there's also then
online there's an Instagram account I
think which is or it's either tumblr or
Instagram of girls who have clearly been
photographed by someone who's gone I'm a
photographer
oh yeah yeah and they're posing like
milk on their head
like yeah yeah should we do some emails
so do you know so when we first started
the podcast we answered we tried to
answer a lot of people's problems but
that's nice we quickly found out the
brain decides roasting them so you lost
them worse than I do you can roll some
lamb well I might I don't know what how
bad are they you have no idea what's
coming at you right now because I've so
I know that all the recent ones you
don't read my will be specifically in
relation to you coming on the show
because I tweeted out all right girl
so if you've got problems that you want
a girl's opinion on I'm here no you're
good at giving advice you're a life
coach yeah I did so all the recent ones
will be like middle of the night chicks
yep succeed over a thousand emails a
week so this morning just a small that's
quite a lot that is that's quite a lot
just this week I've had someone email me
about how to get an part and extra part
on EastEnders where they can get
rhinoplasty done and send me a whole
email about shower call and it like just
it just worried about our necks that's
my sweet and is like I know you're not
as famous as Cheryl call clearly clearly
I'm not joking I was scrolling standard
email like it's really sweet but um I
think people think I'm Google I don't
know why people are asking some things I
don't understand
yeah we're you almond and so I know
everything are you trying to say I've
just read a little bit the email that
the first three words I've read of
masturbation there we go guys
masturbation addiction give this person
a name Dave brilliant we because he also
has a masturbation addiction is it diff
well he verbally ranks himself off quite
a lot yeah
and Manchester United moving on ever
since I discovered the art of muster
bees she's me hi Lawrence Jordi and
Fernando Torres ever since I discovered
the arts of masturbation three years ago
I've blanked off at least once or twice
every single day since then believe it
or not I had a girlfriend during I'm
sorry how many years ago just three how
old is he we'll find out believe it or
not I do feel foreign in this during
this time when she ended things at a
time it felt like the best day of my
life as it meant I could watch porn how
was upon hours without being disturbed
however she was interrupting his porn
watcher - she's not gonna the door he's
gone I was just about your girlfriend's
here however recently although this is
this feeling kicked in deeper when I
failed my a-levels because I spent more
time researching
Hendra lust and Rachel star of sin
Kendra Ellis okay should you feel Kendra
life I don't think that's over your name
no definitely not no I'm surprised she's
changed by people maybe other man yeah
because old buses instead of researching
the rules of law I've realized porn is
affecting my life however I'm deep into
this addiction and I can't stop I'm at a
point right now where I don't even watch
porn to pleasure but as a routine Wow I
know Jordie was an extreme poverty and
abuse and I know he's calmed down since
his peak how does he know I've said I
used to watch a lot of porn when I was a
teenager and I've mentioned it we've got
a lot of hours to kill in this podcast a
lot of things come out and you've calmed
down that's ways I would say so because
I mean YouTube's opened a lot of doors
to no means get the real thing now
who is that woman to distract him from
well yeah but the thing is I don't think
he's appreciating what it's like to be
with a real woman as opposed to the
problem is for men you get into a habit
of where because it's a screen it's a
different woman every night in your mind
it's like variety so then when you have
to go from that the one girlfriend the
first sort of month or whatever is
exciting but eventually you're used to
the habit of a new thing all the time
really yeah and also I would say if the
girl doesn't watch porn and you do their
levels are different or completely what
you mean is enjoy what you do isn't the
same as even saying that but like
there's a different like conversation
there isn't and I got it yeah so yeah I
think Dave let's just think about the
exam worried about Dave as you know it's
like well no it's literally [__] his
life up at this point but what I don't
get and this is my thoughts on life
anyway like Dave say he's doing law
right but he loves honking off pawn
loves it go get it right once or twice a
day once tiny Louis do you think he's
read a day just yeah exactly like eat so
what I would say stay if one cuff over
laws you could do that or you could stop
doing law and find something to do with
sex that he could make his life director
believe me there can be big money I hope
I should live III documentary on it oh
why is it his wife
yeah yeah yeah and you guys were there
but not I was so much freeport and make
sure that people can't be making money
from porn now not as much have to go
okay people are still make important a
lot of so there must be a monthly money
in it somewhere
and their dildos and stuff you can sell
on this I about something accessorize
accessories yeah don't know we can
accessorize if you're actually got
forged by a PR company yesterday who
want to give me sex toys do you find
that's a little bit I'm you like is that
sort to show on your channel than that
yeah I am NOT doing that it's it's
slightly like where does a new Widow I
was gonna say is that he's not the
reason they came to you I don't know
okay good it could be that I just talked
or no matter talked about sex it's open
just generally they probably think you
need someone to be like that but I I
think there's a level like I'm totally
fine talking about sex doesn't really
bother me that much but then also Mike
doesn't need to know yeah
did they offer much brand deal money for
that sort of thing with me at this point
we didn't negotiate any money just as
many they were really high-end they were
like 150 pound plus sex toys hey second
wife isn't she free toys paid and all
day like I used to love I've got some
friends that run a podcast as well and
whenever they used to get sort of crap
sponsorship deals they asked for the
most unreasonable stuff so once they got
offered Budweiser deal I think it was
and they just said deliver as much beer
as humanly possible to this address but
they won't have it was humanly possible
that's amazing
you'd be surprised what you can get like
my dive oh yeah well I've had loads of
free stuff that just I'm like brilliant
can you pass the dildo deals over 200 I
would I needed indle why not this other
stop fly don't just don't just dismiss
my Cochran's lubricant lubricant Connie
awesome that over as much lubricants
humanly possible
number one true joy details of a foxy
alright so what do we what do we do
about saving slides I'm Dave yeah you
might need all of that wine I am self
until he's seen this is a problem I'm
asking him to reframe this [__] already
all over the place right because
seriously
is it a problem always at human nature
we like sex like it's a norm on a master
phone yeah twice a day it's not ten
times a day it's my life coach if you I
just think you should reframe it and go
look I'm not really into law as much as
I'm into Kendra loss yeah and I and
Rachel star and I would rather be doing
that doing them obviously you can do
stuff to do with porn no that's your
passion do something to do tell about it
caught but then maybe but then okay the
maybe just needs to put in levels of
boundaries for himself there we go you
were yeah no one can it work or I'm
gonna I'm gonna finish finish this essay
on law and then whether that's brilliant
no thanks genuine leads by a few teenage
boy out there you've done my harvest
inferior you're really crack on me
sometimes your brain can't relax and to
get work done until you sort of put the
fire out
yeah but then he seemed to so I'm seeing
do it before mhm and then relax get then
you may go a bit sleepy then
[Music]
so if you do girlfriend in the future
then you also need to be with a girl in
your underpants in a go-cart behind the
crowd [__] is the number plate that
would be grown women yeah I'm a Tyne
Bridge you don't have to photoshop that
assignments could we get a lot of people
for shopping things can we just just
approach the Normans and the Whale me
she said that that was the ultimate in
icing on a joke so to speak anyway so
okay so Dave look just reframe it you've
all right mate just don't you know like
don't be so preoccupied if you can like
just try and find time to eat and to
sleep and if there's room for a
girlfriend just
sure that she is as freaky as you and
she's into it as much if she's not this
there will be girls out there just it's
cool just hatteras just concentrate on
law and banking for now
yeah and it's fine every time do it just
yeah just time make sure you if you but
if not then try and find something in
the sex industry then let's also be
honest I think in England people so in
there yeah we're sure absolutely ashamed
everything I know he was talking about
grief early and I wish him to agree for
a shame yes wishing but every night we
just we hate British Wall Street where
he says he has to masturbate a few times
I'm just afraid this job just to feed
the geese is a job
keep the blood flow below the belt and
he doesn't feel a shame about it
he's open about its Polly's lifestyle
maybe an breaks that side of things if
you doesn't that mean weird and then
maybe more be more likely to attract to
go because while I know about this yeah
and he's it's putting out there first
day we were talking about being real and
being like people can't really like
catch you out on stuff if you read about
it though isn't it because when you
first meet a girl and you just go I'm
just just gonna put the title of it I'll
be right back yeah that would be unusual
but he said he prefers it he's like
she's a discipline I think that's
because they're maybe he's you know he's
only young so I like the girls he's
gonna go out if I'm gonna be fairly
inexperienced and young and yeah didn't
like maybe they're just a bit nervous
and shy and maybe you know Dave you
could take them on that journey well
that's very true a lot of the time and
you just have to be open about that yeah
okay so Dave it's all right it's all
right just you posted about you yeah I
mean don't like what we got now I think
this is a good one especially to get
your opinion on okay what would you like
to call this person um Steve Steve it's
all very just sensible yeah I know they
go for like cherry dude though anyways
Steve what he doesn't fight I'd like to
remain anonymous that's why we give you
the other name Steve
my question for you is white nice guys
finish last
unlike most uncivilized savages when I
see an unconscious girl I would not make
sexual advances okay that makes him like
what par excellence that makes me a nice
guy because the fact that he's even
quantify and being a nice guy and then
attaching an identity I mean really in
many ways if you see an unconscious
woman don't think that because you did
not have sex with any unusual yeah I
just kept on walking didn't even touch
us yeah should need it
yeah that's why yeah okay so so nice
guys finish last is this worried but see
that makes me a nice guy just
reaffirming his identity yes why is it
that a woman won't sleep with me well I
would never rape oh you know when
they're Chris Chris Chris Rock goes
you're supposed to yeah yeah I would
never write and I text her every day
telling her how pretty she is and how
she should leave her [__] boyfriend I
don't understand what to do as it seems
the only way to get a girl is through
brute force
but I can't even do that please help
kind of God Steve whoa Steve see if
you've made a lot of assumptions in your
yeah Steve that feels like a lot of like
passive-aggressive anger bubbling
surface maybe he needs to do more of
what
I think yeah just we'll get calm down
yeah buddy up so I don't think I don't
think it's a case of nice guys finish
last
but the reason that girls are attracted
to bad lads is not that they want a
wanker it's attractive when people are
confident and that is what is attractive
regardless of and sometimes that goes in
the wrong form but you can so what
you're saying is you can be a nice guy a
nice guy but if you can exude that
confidence that the bad lads have while
still being a gent yeah then you're
getting a good balance I own 100% like
everyone's attractions we just are when
naturally if somebody's got a good high
self-esteem people want to be around
them when you text someone constantly in
a like especially if you're trying to
get them off Association it's not very
attractive unless that's really
reciprocated and you Bothwell into that
space of like in being into each other
like that's not attractive or like there
has to be a level of like and not
gameplay and that's the wrong thing but
like - sort of like flirtin and they've
just chase like you know buddy finds you
know like we were saying earlier about
how Ross pulled me a by nagging me and
that works because without being a
complete wanker if you're a pretty girl
and you go out you get chatted up all
the time like I if you do the same thing
every other guy does how are you going
to stand out from the crowd it's
impossible you're just gonna be one of
the many nice Oneg in the right way
like Ross used to do and they used to do
this like in general to bring people
down a peg or to eat go up to like a
girl and be like do you know you look
like an everyday
who let their thinking like Angelina
gonna say right Lorraine Kelly like like
me none Barash what and they're never on
the back for and he's winning and used
to all the time you'd do with lads as
well a little bit like if they were both
a big bloke he bloke who guards he'd be
like you just bring him down a little
bit because he had no like filter but
that's attractive I'd say I think it's
attractive either way like it's a sin
with girls if if they're like desperate
you know how can you value someone who
doesn't value themselves there's a level
I do have a bit of a problem with that
though because I also think you should
value people anyway
even though they don't see the value you
put it this way right if I take English
Pounds to another country I still value
it because I still know it's got value
back where I'm from yeah so I know well
and you know what girls who didn't value
themselves yeah yeah you don't deserve
the Diamonds the want them no I'll tell
you the ones you've got low self-esteem
who are diamonds to look at they're the
best ones mental as well not because
they don't realize how great they are
and part of the fun is also showing them
that but also part of the fun isn't
having to put up with the [__] who
think that they're great who aren't
actually great you know they're the
Diamonds like so part of that is also
some men some men like to sweep in and
feel like they're showing the girl what
the girl can be and I get that that's a
writ there's a really nice movie Hank
Tom Hanks side to it I think you know
they've got their own personality but I
often think that people justify some
shitty actions towards girl because I
will she know me self-confidence so yeah
you know whatever I don't think that's
the level I think of like sort of its
self-confidence is attractive being
egotistical isn't and being attract
isn't like when people are like the
other ending they think that in our
sister active either and I think
web that whole myth of girls like bad
lads or the nice guys finish last it's
not actually true like I want people to
be nice to me like I don't but there's
also a level of like you know matching
someone a little bit it's like you need
to have be able to have a conversation
and be able to be on top of each other a
bit as well like with with you know like
you know me max would argue over like
grammar or whatever like they'll be like
something I would say or something in he
try and pull me up on it would be like
sort of battling each other but it's fun
but it's fun and it's not like I'm
better than you or do you know
demoralizing or like trying to put you
down or anything but I think yeah I just
I don't think it's a case of having to
pretend to be like a tough guy or
anything like that I don't necessarily
think that's attractive either one thing
I do have a bit obviously this email
sort of addresses that is he says I
would never rape man he also says I mean
that's just ludicrous it's ridiculous
but it does sort of show I think when
you're a teenage boy or a lot of teenage
boys get feelings where they do feel
like real sexual urges and they don't
feel like they can control them and
especially like the current climate
where grown men haven't been able to
control their sexual urges and those
guys maybe deserve to be shamed because
I think how I knew what they were doing
yeah there's also a feeling that I think
when you're young you don't understand
that so well and that doesn't it doesn't
mean excuse doesn't excuse it but at the
same time I feel like some people they
need a space to be able to talk about
that because they're feeling about those
things I'd totally agree that and I
think when we're talking about porn and
stuff earlier I think there is because
there's so much accident again I'm not
it's not against porn but I'm saying
there's so much access to it like you go
onto Twitter and you accidentally type
anything like it could be a girl's name
it could be Kendra and you tell it in
you will get hardcore porn not like like
softcore like really graphic stuff like
I don't really think that young people
have the brain capacity to really
understand the the nuance of that and
like you know we as adults can look at
that and go okay so that's well-lit
whatever that's there's two consenting
adults like this thing with you I just
don't say in my
know what you're looking at is an
illustrative nor that yeah and you've
probably as an adult had some sexual
experiences where you know kind of
what's mean and what's nine and what's
kind of part of the phone and where the
levels are but if you're a teenage boy
particularly full of testosterone and
what you're seeing is you know sometimes
simulated rape which might be fine in in
that in a concern relationship
relationship alright yeah that might be
fine for that but if that's what you'll
see and your idea of sex is really
skewered and and then maybe you read and
stuff in the paper and stuff and you
think then then I've got to be a blocky
block and you see things like Geordie
Shore and stuff like that and in those
came and those blocks are idiots I'm
sorry like who what are you talking
about like the way they talk is just I
mean I don't find it attractive in this
I mean I don't spice confidence the way
it's false confidence and it's it's
pretty gross like I just think when I
say that I'm my slave like goodbye I
went to Newcastle not long ago for a
night out and I hadn't been for ages I'm
not gonna lie there's been a shift you
must have seen it in lads I feel like I
figured on it belong in a time frame
like fifty years ago
this is this is like harsh because that
it's not really their fault either
because they're part of this everyone
everyone wants to blend in so they've
all gone with it and the noise and it's
like I was what did you see them I was
being chatted up by a lad and I didn't I
assumed like this is real like sounds
really so it'll but I assumed it was pay
from the way locked like my you know my
era it was like faked hand it's eyebrow
so clock to the like in Shiva their
lives like really like done and he he
may have had makeup on and again I'm not
judging any of this surface that's what
he wanted but I'm just saying that as a
woman I he was talking to me for fight
and added a drink so I went she all
chatting me up on yeah cuz I first had a
drink so doesn't bother and he was like
yeah and I was like oh
okay yeah here's some tips yes exactly
what I did and I said I'm not as harsh
but like I say I really like genuine
like I'm not into that
I think that's gonna wear makeup for a
start like if you're from Newcastle I
sort of I take it with don't self I saw
like no it's alright there is what they
do but it's north I'm like what the [__]
is going on I'm just I don't know
whether it's not it's not that that
bothers me it's more than I'm like is it
like this keeping up with the Jones like
the feel it is it's thick corner they've
got I mean I lived in Essex going from
Newcastle a sex in Essex they've been
wearing makeup and they've been doing
their eyebrows for yes and it was a
cultural thing down there and I know
snore that's what comes out and laugh
our heads off at it but it's like
everyone's just insane with the girls
they've all blended in all their faces
are like surgery doc to the max
everybody looks the same and they're
talking this talk and I don't even think
they believe it like the lads you know I
saw a bum down I'm like like is there
any girl I've been into that if I like
and I'm like by fun like the least
prudish person and I don't give a [__]
what you do but I'm like that's not
attractive like don't talk to me like
that I don't talk to girls like that and
but then the girls must be accepting
that as well and it's certainly it's one
thing when you talk to your mates like
that about losses because I'll [__]
do that please you were no around Alice
as well if they're the right goes an
angle on that level with them I mean we
could have a joke about that and I'd
bounce straight back with you but it
wouldn't be like a disrespect it isn't
there is a level and I think this tacit
acceptance of it I mean like that's what
I mean
that's outrageous I mean nobody should
be thinking if there's an unconscious
girl I'm a good person because I didn't
rape her like what I mean I'm glad yeah
girl you saw on the floor but why are we
having this conversation scale to it
there's a skin and I think you write
like this this sort of our blocks being
young men being given like the right
advice about sex probably not I need
what's gonna be hopping in the 15 years
is what I'm thinking
back in the day
that ago so this is how you shave now
that we like and this is how you put
your foundation honestly but then
obviously in the 80s we've already been
through that's what I got to figure a
lot of guys in Newcastle even in
Liverpool that people would have been
putting honestly if you watch me and you
wear makeup in your man saw it I feel
like there are guys who wear eye makeup
I was buying makeup the other days of
present and which ultimately don't
always do that as a present Helen easily
unless you've had it requested to see
what's wrong that's exact what I thought
when I receive what the president I was
like does this look like I'm trying to
but why given a Bob sux
what is clever is subscribe to the
emails and then every time some new
makeup comes out the point is they were
saying to me more and more guys go in
and get like eyeliner in those sorts of
things I'm not I'm not totally against
that I don't I don't absolutely hate it
I think there's just a level like what I
don't like or find attractive in
probably either and I maybe I'll let
girls off a little bit but in blocks is
being a try-hard like miss topic I don't
really I like people to be themselves so
I if someone's really done and and even
like gym stuff let me know you're into
gym soft but when people are like mega
mega like ripped and Ross used to say
this is what I like he was like like
there's no space for anyone else like
you're that into yourself there's not
much space for an apartment to to to
actually achieve a physical your whole
life has to be that actually I work that
out a while back was like to become that
elite level of like bodybuilder tiny no
need you have to be an office assistant
and you know we've had extreme weight
lifters on this show while the world
Strongest Man and he said I'm a [__]
narcissist without a doubt but but also
I'm how long is that it maintainable for
and what you willing to sacrifice to
have a six-pack like because if you've
got a natural six-pack then good for you
but if you're like you're killing
yourself and your whole life revolves
are on a six part I just think it's
pointless to be honest yeah you've got I
think what then what the end goal is
overall with that stuff
maintain a decent physique is great but
I don't you should have your life it's
like if if I look at someone in there
like you know they've had surgery done
in them and I'm like it's it makes me
feel like you're really on confident
with who you are not really found later
have you seen the Geordie Shore girls
and all the surgery the way it makes me
feel really sad and I read and I don't
read soft like they gossip magazines so
far I've read psychologies magazine like
I don't and I'm not trying to be like a
Artie Wonka that's just because I took a
conscious step and actually Russ was
largely impactful in that because he was
like this is bollocks like what you
eating this stuff more like and like
heat magazine and things like that and I
know they have the place in terms of
trashy fun stuff throw away stuff but if
you read solely that you feel miserable
and my my mom still read stuff like that
and there was stuff at my house at Shiva
now I took a second so I've looked
through cuz I you know I need to kinda
know what's going on whatever flick
through and there was a interview by
someone on a reality show girl and there
was a few comments that stood out for me
one was they asked if she had any
surgery done it and she said no and she
said I'm not really into she's like I
haven't had anything she went I'm not
really into surgery I have had my boobs
done and my lips buttoned and I was like
is that like Justin nothing sir that's
almost considered irregular like those
Sunday yeah that's like oh yeah but I
mean I got a bench and then the second
comment was they asked him about having
sex on telly and she was like well my
mum and dad - fine with it and they've
just said like everybody else is donated
so why not and I'm like I did a video on
it cuz I was a few min I was like if you
want that girl's parents you have a bad
parent my judge it was sort of a like
who like what like what never no way out
where we're like that's totally fine
babe if you can make some money from
that
no that's desperation is what I get from
that those like you literally your life
start [__] that you think you know my
daughter gets [__] on TV that might
make us a few quid as well and
like surge your thing like I'm totally
not against surgery like and if it makes
you but it's the level of it like if you
get your boobs don't you want you've had
small boobs and you're like really want
big boobs sound if you then want to like
overhaul and there's one of the girls I
think it's Charlotte I'm in Geordie
Shore and and I'm not judging her at all
because she's been shoved into the
spotlight and all I see I just feel
sorry for her because I there's a
different level now they may do in TV
from being young I kind of grew up in
the industry and it wasn't that kind of
high fame but it was like I just kind of
learned what the industry was like and
how silly and make-believe it all is and
I never took it serious and I never have
whereas these people now go on from no
one to major major big TV stuff and then
everyone's gone you Oakley and you mean
getting you this I mean I grew up on
telly and people said it's me and I was
at such such low confidence when I was
growing up on television because of it
and I think these people are being like
thrust into the media spotlight and then
it's a wonder why they were all like
chopping my face as to pieces you know
I'm and sadly they all look the same
like they've all got the same search as
women it's very little variety in the
looks lost a meal
this one says Lawrence Bryant and first
we know guess I'm 27 from the US and you
can use my name if I can't pronounce it
make something up
apparently his name is Gerardo Torrado
was a nice Jerrod or was seen us we will
use your name of Jurado
jersey knit receiver sounds like
something upon your hair head if you
lose your doors like you just use
Recinos twice a day kurodo sounds like a
big call a big forward going yeah but
the comuneros on the substance
[Music]
kind of like a young true Geordie my
youth was me and will be the children my
trying to count like young few joining
my youth have spent eating so girl was
not something I ever imagined was I was
gonna do but I lost the weight two and a
half stone you've got a weight mommy -
good boy
and thus it's done since they're much
better with girls mostly because I've
got a much more confident to my ability
to speak to women love a monoid but for
over ten years I've always been into one
girl more than the other ones
oh wow I asked her out when we were
young 18 and again at 21 but nothing
ever happened since then we stopped
talking until a year ago a year and half
yeah we spoke every day since she's my
closest friend and she knows all my
stories and I know all hers including
each other sex stories I don't know if
giving it one last go and telling her
how I feel is a good idea or well I will
it [__] up our friendship if I if I'm
ever in London again I'll buy you a
couple of shots of tequila and a pint
for true Geordie in Laurens lovely a
meal well my thoughts are if she was
into you she would have said by now I
just think she's just not I don't I
think he could be honest with her
because they seem like they're pretty
honest with each other and he can say
look I've got these feelings I need to
deal with them because unless you feel
same but I don't think I don't think she
does cuz he's retired
she'll have time I know like the two
stones gone and stuff but I'm guessing
love but you know sorry that's really
good no but I just think maybe maybe Lee
I think teller and just say look I'm
dealing with like don't put the pressure
on her but just be like look this is how
he feeling but I think maybe he feels
this way about because they've had this
like intimate journey as friends yeah
and she's been along that path with him
but maybe he's just not experienced that
with anyone else and if he's fixated on
her and he's not really allowing that to
come into his life and and some guys do
do that and I
a friend of ours to hold bear and friend
that he loved doing it ruin their
friendship that problem there's always
that argument is there can boys and
girls be friends yeah it's good question
I think I think I think they can but I
think there is always there could always
be a sexual element when it's two
straight straight people like I think
you can definitely have friends pink and
gay people be friends well yeah they can
but again the potential for anything I
think yeah there's potential with
anything I guess but I think there
definitely is that element of that
probably more so and not being sexist
but it's more sore from the lad
then the girl I I think the majority of
the time and I would say that would be
the case oh I'm feeling it actually just
remembered I've been in a situation
where the girl like fancied me and I was
like that's just not coming here others
and as much as I actually quite one do
like in my head I'm thinking I could
just go off or something like that right
now there's just but it was friendship
yeah and then that's when I faced that
situation oh boy I don't know you can't
be friends if the bully is are good
friends but I think this it's a pattern
or like I guess they've been friends for
a long time so there's there's like that
you see it's good good a building block
friendship isn't the for a relationship
but do you think they left it too long
friendship is definitely a great
foundation but I think there has to be
even if it's just I quite think you're
attractive even if it's not like of well
fancied you the first second I met year
yeah it could just be that person and
I've got a girl that I was coaching for
a long time in for ages she was gone out
of this awful bloke and she couldn't get
over him and I work with her on a main
sentenced often and saying look the
perfect bloke that you're talking about
is not going to come into this situation
why would the perfect block that you're
telling me you want come into this drama
if this [__] hanging around in the
background ain't coming into that
because perfect block doesn't want that
you want drama you just said he doesn't
you know like and when she stopped
looking and she got rid of [__] blog
actually the
friend that was around just in their
group suddenly she yeah and she's now
having a baby with them and all is good
oh shut up
Jenna I have to say I'm a bit of a
romantic so if I was him I'm going for
it
I'm good one day I'm turning up with
flowers knowledge but that's too much
because then she'll be like there was
it's a bit neater you would go for it I
would because I know I'm just a risking
a bus that's odd I'd rather risk the
whole friendship and potentially life
always thinking we should still see it
you should say this is how I feel Oh
like hundred percent I feel like this
I've been in love with for ages
is that like pop me up my misery is ever
gonna be that and she probably needs a
reality check doesn't if he's wondering
yeah but then roofie like you said
you've gotta take a risk at night if you
do have to just Goergen or this is how i
feel right you're wrong like it is what
it is and like you said if he just get a
big fat nor then he moves on any-any
opens up the possibilities for future
and then yeah and then you'll find
someone will flee and it'll think
actually that's I've moved on it's is
good in the world
the thing is he would maybe lose the
friendship at that point and that's
really easy really a friend a good point
yeah if it's not good of a friendship
would she ditch him although
han-soo part the problem is i mean i
mean i guess if he's told her that and
then he's bringing around someone else
to that friendship there's always gonna
be a question mark yeah everyone listen
everyone I also grow we're not it is
it's time twists and turns
everyone has that one felt around the
world and you cannot really impact
anybody's decisions and how they see it
and how they don't and how they feel
about you and how they don't is not your
responsibility if there's one thing we
learn from micro growth don't go on
roofs and painting your eyes literally
dropping me stuff I wasn't really watch
biker of a bill fun as a nine-year-old
no
judolette casualty as well I still
remember the truth I've done casually
three times I not different characters
yeah I played a girl who did a boob job
the first time that burst wrong did you
have to what how did you play that
character do you have to have one bigger
than me no I was pregnant at the time
top boobs were massive and they're smart
to move I was early stage of pregnancy
with boobs on so it was fine yes I got
pregnant just for that the boobs yeah
that one else to play a common but oh
yeah played a stripper who shared a
seizure that's always nice for casual
you won't have a seizure in casual
tedious like it seems like a tick in the
box like crack it on the bail seizure in
casualty and then the last one I did in
casualty I played a girl who got raped
so going back to earlier no I was it was
it was actually really really horrible
story down that one but that yeah that I
am I was she was raped in an alley by a
friend it was a hard role to play that
one it was really intense really intense
I actually didn't want to we played like
the the club scenes before and and then
she goes out into the alley and she
snogs the brother and then the other
brother came in and was like move out
the way it's really horrible it was
really gruesome but the director
directed me in Byker Grove guy called
Graham Harper who did a lot of the
Doctor Who stuff really really great guy
and he was really conscious of the fact
that I still have to act what's
happening it's actually really like
quite an intimate
creation but we did it saw that I didn't
meet the actor who played the rapist
toll on seconds anyone who mates with
him like too much I just wanted to meet
it real time and it was actually really
weird because it was in an alley like in
the dark in the you know the rain and
stuff and like it was a bit miserable
but I didn't feel like unsafe right yeah
I think it was totally fine but it made
it very realistic it was quite gruesome
the stuff that was shot like POV shots
of it and that is pretty mingun I was
free stunned to hear how much the guys
in casualty or on Charlie a lot of you
know the extras are on decent as an
actor's like a few stop like a few
episodes I stuff you like am I getting
this wrong yeah shall I sit back and
stop playing roles and actually just for
you next up because these people are we
have all week I mean like over the long
term that probably make them make more
money like just walking around going
scalpel
yeah is boring or like you know I enjoy
if I'm good if I go back to acting which
is the minute I'm like I probably will
do something but like TV is definitely
sort of calling a bit but I just I can't
do the audition side anymore I saw
something weird because now you saw a
lot of Fame as a real person as well
she's kind of she liked to be in action
this is nice to be yourself as opposed
to being currently that's weird to me
cause it I never ever wanted that
initially and then I started to just
talk over myself and people always used
to say to me you should do present and I
was like I don't mean oh like what like
why and like then I just started doing
YouTube and I started doing a first
often I realized I actually do quite
like that and now I feel like I'm gonna
point my life where I want to do
something more impactful then like just
part that actually brings us on to what
you're doing right now you do in life
culture and you've just started
something yesterday actually I yeah I
was well exciting and I got my phone
yeah because my phone's like flagging up
at me and I basically I put together
online courses on mindset positive
mindset and that kind of stuff in that's
been something that I've done for the
last few years it was a I started to
when I became like started doing the
life coaching and stuff was around the
time that Ross was diagnosed I've always
been into it
because as an actor you have to work on
your mind and you have to have good
resilience and so I always was did self
development type stuff and read about a
million books a week on that kind of
stuff like constantly reading on it and
when Ross was diagnosed I had to really
work on myself and I just found that I
attracted people that needed me to work
with them and I just used to do it and
then eventually I realized actually this
could be something I do as a business in
some capacity and I want it to be closer
to home so I used to do sessions via
Skype so I can speak to anyone around
the world
that's one-on-one stuff and then I
realized actually in terms of finances
and stuff to have a more regular wage
and have to do less work overall was to
build this sort of income nut and you
know you don't have to do as much so I
built online courses and so I've just
released a new one and this is the first
one since Ross was Ross died and the
reason I kind of did it was a nice focus
for me but also because I've built this
new following of people who are either
gone through similar stuff will resonate
with me in some capacity that I kind of
wanted to go because that you know
obviously let you guys I get a lot of
emails of people wanting to know like
how am i positive how do I deal with
life whether that's you know dealing
with death and health stuff or it's just
like you know I want too much or
whatever I like it whatever level it is
and so I just I thought I need to just
do something I need to put this together
now so I put together this 21-day online
course it's called the happy me project
it's you get daily audios you get a
workbook to work through every day
there's videos on specific actually not
dissimilar to what you guys do but I put
it out there to my followers what are
you common like mindset issues that
you're going through and a lot of the
same stuff comes up time and time again
social anxiety and whatever like loads
of stuff that people sort of do so I'll
put that in there as well there's lots
of worksheets there's a Facebook group
for people to kind of be supported in
that and I'll jump in there and do live
stuff and things and answer questions
for people as well and but I've put it
at 30 quid which is ridiculous
considering the work that I put into it
but I'll put it at that level because I
wanted more people to be able to get it
because it's basic stuff like you can
tell by the way I talk like any mindset
so if I don't want it to be like me
flexing my like look at me I know my
stuff like it doesn't need to be that I
want you to get it it's profitable it's
practical like I want people know
[__] like I want people to
understand it I want it to be not
everybody that you know everybody in
self development and mindset sort of
circles gets this stuff but I'm like I
don't care like it needs to be like your
brick layer who's struggling with
depression it doesn't know how to deal
with it or you know the lad at school
who's struggling secretly and he doesn't
really know how to deal with it that
matters to me more and it's something
I'm so passionate about because like I
said too early I like sometimes I get a
little bit and maybe this is my own
issues to deal with but sometimes people
put me on a pedestal like like look at
her like she's got her [__] together and
I'm like like I said to you it's it
seems a little bit like it's almost like
harsh on me in some ways because I work
on that every day like I work on my
mindset when I feel something coming up
I deal with it I do the stuff that I've
put into the course whether it's
meditation or whether it's you know
gratitude or for journaling or whatever
other things that I do and it's almost
like know if somebody had like the
ripped abs you wouldn't go look at them
with their natural ripped abs they're
just amazing they're just amazing people
that's why they've got ripped ABS you
would understand that they go to the gym
every day and it's the same with me like
with mindset stuff I know I'm strong as
[__] like I know my mindset is unusual
and all that but equally it's not
unobtainable like the stuff I'm doing if
you do the stuff that I'm doing you will
find benefit in it and so this cause was
put together for that exact reason where
it's like look it's not over complicated
you've got a workbook you do the work in
the work but it's not law it's not
school you fill it out on a night time
there's some questions to get you
thinking about stuff you listen to an
audio in the morning which will get you
in a good for your mind it'll be
different topics every day there's
challenges for you to do this there's
videos for you to look through as you're
going and just wanted it to be something
I can direct people to because also my
time is precious and I don't want to
give away too much of my time or energy
and
to protect myself in that way as well
and I've only taken on a few new clients
over the last like month or so because I
also can't deal with too much of
people's negativity as well myself I
gotta protect my own anything yeah
because you're vested in your own
emotions and to these people and being
around someone who is struggling and the
company for help is also gonna you're
gonna feel what they're feeling and yeah
like I'm an empath like I do feel
people's energy or not and so that I've
had to put boundaries on that and I sort
of I attract a different kind of client
now with different to what I did I used
to just be like I help you all and then
I realize that Wow like some people need
help I couldn't really deal with that so
those people can do the online stuff and
I can be there as a background support
whereas I tend to only work business in
mindset so I tend to it with female
entrepreneurs what on one on one because
I can give them one-on-one stuff that
they can do and they will do it and
they'll it will be practical and
positive whereas I'm not massively into
working one-on-one with people who like
certainly I wouldn't work with
deep-seated issues with people because
I'm not a psychologist
I'm a life of course it was the
difference like sphere but in terms of
the you know positive mindset practical
stuff that people can do the happy may
project online stuff is is great and I'm
going to be doing some workshops on that
as well in in December I'm doing on the
3rd of December I'm doing one in
Coventry because I'm lazy and I like to
be close to my house um but I'll be I'm
gonna kind of just go where people want
me so like a lot of people are asking me
to go at different cities in the UK and
I might not get enough people now come
and I'll talk and we'll do some stuff
together but it's kind of just putting
out there and you know see laddish one I
don't have many lads I think that's
about to change
I think it is good well we'll put all of
your links in the description for
everything that you do and everyone who
wants to get in touch I'll follow you or
I can do that any more questions from
you me I've got one left
wicked how would you like to be
remembered that's a big question
finish on a big one um you know what I
just would like to be remembered as
somebody who gave life a shot and just
wasn't scared to try and I live my life
by very geordie saying shy Ben's getting
out and I have winged life I still don't
know how like I get up and do what I
want and where the claws that I want and
just normally have a proper job like and
I love that and it's purely because I
just wing it and try and have a goal so
just one when I'm dead people squash
give it a shot and she late try and help
people and try to make an impact than
that that's enough I think you're doing
nothing yet you're in inspiration and
I'm really happy that you were the first
woman yeah I know was saying to you
earlier my dads are fun after Sean I
didn't know him and he's called Brian
Wow sure the big bro yeah yeah and he
works on the rigs as well so there's
lots of connections and we obviously
follow you maybe for that reason but but
you said yeah he's when I said I was
coming on the show he was like he's
amazing no you know blowen says I'm
kinda pasties watch yeah well if
everyone has enjoyed this make sure you
lot like the video subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you later